Four 3 two hello everybody sorry we're
so late
hello I don't I'm not going to pass the
blame to anyone today but I am looking
at you
Alfredo who look at his poor Alfredo who
is what
happen I think it's Ka that flipped it
over
okay a happy Friday to all happy Friday
we have a fantastic show planned here as
you can see by our beautiful pictures of
us as as children me and Ela the
thumbnail M um how old were you in that
photo I don't actually know um looking
at it I don't know maybe four I guess I
would be about the same
age but everyone says I look just like
Theodore you really do it's so funny
baby wants yeah it is f i mean listen
when we were babies he looked like
Babywise and Bruce too we all starting
from the same baby M then we're
deviating a little bit from there but
when um who was it I think my mom put
the my baby photo next to Bruce baby
photo he looks a lot like me too that's
interesting very weird when I see them
next to you it's like a copy of you what
do we make of that well we are the
parents right that's true that means we
know for sure that your uh gyno didn't
yes p a fast one
freak freak ass gyos um can you actually
send me the thumbnail so I can pull up
those
photos but we have one of everybody and
I don't expect this to be hard but it
will be cute that we have baby photos of
every have we not done
this
no oh was the parents
okay and then who was whose mom was
super hot was that Ian or Sam
uh no I remember ab's Mom is pretty but
she wasn't
the okay excuse
me I'm just saying like she wasn't she
was just not my specific type is what I
was saying looking for your she's very
beautiful maybe she reminds you of
someone it was Love's mom it was Love's
mom I think it was my mom yes yeah can
you drop a picture of your mom it's
Mommy make at the moment
unfortunately okay look at this so here
is Ela little baby Ela here's here I am
that fa so when I see this face of me
that's Brucey is that like how Brucey
looks but then here's Theodore which
obviously
oh the cutest thing what am I
eating so
cute always eating cuz now I see my kids
love it and I just love my boys
yeah Brucey gives me this whole this
kind of like brigh eyed just Joy face
all the
time so we got pictures of
everybody and uh we're going to we're
going to say who are these folks and
we're going to rate them on cuteness
scale from 1 to 10 they'll be a loser
and a
winner so if you're an ugly
baby great you're about to get clowned
on no I'm just kidding we of course will
not be doing
that uh um I mean let's let's not rule
anything out you want to do a tear
list baby tear list no it's
terrible uh oh okay here we go huge
announcement guys gamer Subs we are
finally ready to
launch our very
own drink
flavor and look at look at what a uh
they're rolling out the red carpet for
us at gamer
Subs look at
this right here boom right on the H page
that's Sigma wow M looks just like you I
wish the well this one's caffeine free
but you you have both options for me oh
that one's yours okay yeah caffine free
option this is the one I add what the
heck I'm taking this home with me so
here we have our proprietary
blend
of it's here's what's cool and
interesting about it it's a little bit
spicy mhm yes
sir and it's a little bit Margarita mhm
and it's got little Citrus really hating
the this is my first time trying the the
final load wait is it really yeah you
didn't try it earlier this week no live
taste test right now the final
load oh dude
oh that's the best flavor let's go all
different Flav that's the best flavor
yeah it reminds me of like Ecto you guys
remember that Ecto Cooler the one with
Slimer on it everybody loves yeah yeah
yeah giving that dude this is
good I've been wanting something sweet M
and then I drank this and I was like oo
this pop for you it says the way they
describe it on the website is awesome
they go
uh here 100 serving you guys what really
that's what they yeah 100 servings dude
it's the ultimate energy and Focus
Formula designed to level up your gaming
wa it's got vitamin B2 they said about
all their yeah it's a it's also like a
multivitamin vitamin B12 W I need that
there it is good for me it's got
everything you need I don't think you
need food
right no sugar right no sugar no no
sugar this is perfect keto friendly no
sugar neut tropics
I'm like Cofe I'm constantly depressed
that I can't have as much coffee as I
want and caffeine and so I'm always
looking for interesting drinks right now
D and this is exactly what I need right
now yeah nice cold beverage like that so
here's the deal if you guys want to get
your very own Sigma brain uh drink and
look at this dude everybody's going to
be wanting this everybody on the website
is rushing to get their hands on the
sigma brain definitely they are looking
to level up their game
definitely so here's the deal I'm just
oh wait are they going to oh there's an
important question I'll do I'll do it at
the mid R time I I'm seeing a few people
asking is there a
cup and it's not here yet yeah it's
there's there is a cup but unfortunately
it's not launching at the same time it
it should be launching very soon the cup
will be epic mhm I'd also we designed
that too I really like the art on the C
I do really like the art a cup with this
art would be sick but the our art ours
is yeah ours great so I'll more to come
on this but very exciting uh cheers and
this is the color I wanted to put cheers
my dude cheers my dude transparent one
so you guys could see the color uhuh
sick sick looks tasty cheers my
dude love you cheers my
dude homo
sapian love you from one Homo Sapien to
another oh that spicy is nice perks you
up a little bit mhm little kick well
everybody likes spicy Margaritas that's
like the drink right now is it yeah I
swear to God that's just like I mean I
liked them too but I didn't know it was
it was in at the moment I think it is to
this drink is the summer this drink is
crazy with ice it's it goes crazy with
ice no but the spice the eyes it's just
kind of really really refreshing and you
know love is The Connoisseur you it from
love you guys this is definitely my Top
flavor of gamer it's a juicer all
different flavors it's there it is all
different flavors thank you Jimmy Lee
Olive and
cam Olive
Olivia you guys are matching again oh
yeah you guys are matching again what
the freak hey girl what is happening you
look so pretty
y I love this shirt me too that's the
Corduroy or is
it is that from Trixie yeah yeah cute is
it denim or it is denim yeah it's uh
it's twill I think technically P twill
here let me open up uh you can talk
about it a little bit I just posted a
Tik Tok with uh with with Trixie herself
watch I saw I literally the can't
believe Trixie yep love this
already TI
oh that was good I feel like the
sound looks delayed here cuz it's it is
lined up there's a tiny bit of delay on
our but on TI to you yeah
nice that's it that's everything bro
that is everything living that Tik Tok
life let's go
girl well the The Collection came out
yesterday it's been so fun seeing
everyone's reactions here let me pull up
the website um it's doing really well
yeah it's just been nice see excitement
really ex just like a good
wholesome uh everybody's liking it I
can't wait to get my hands on this shirt
cuz I guess it's not in yet it's a
pre-order right there was a delay with
the shipment and the pants too yeah see
I want that do you want to know what's
the story why it's delayed it's so funny
um oh wow lots sold out it's like in a
everything's F it's like in a one of
those like big cargo things like a boat
yeah yeah shipping container it's in a
big container together with somebody
else's stuff mhm and for us it was only
like two items in that big container
boxes yeah I mean only two styles of us
and the rest of the container is
something else yeah and they got stopped
for drugs and they're getting like
they're getting like yeah like really
pulled for
drugs and so our stuff got caught up in
this what you we got put in the drug
trafficking yes and that's our first
part that never happened to us come on
man why we get put in the drug
trafficking one bro we're just trying to
traffic in t-shirts
man oh that is interesting pretty how
did you find that out what did they tell
you um because there's like you know a
forwarder company that we use they help
with all the logistics of bringing it in
yeah and so they told us that that's
what happened it's been pulled over for
that and so what's the ETA what do they
say is going to happen they're working
on getting our stuff out of there
because they didn't pull us they pulled
the other stuff so so I wonder if there
were drugs in it I I know they were I no
I don't know if there were but I'm
wondering too well if it's from China
it's probably probably be like fentol
and cuz I'm pretty sure that all
gets made in
China and I think it gets shipped in by
you know like that that's crazy
Yeah by four yo we got on the fenal
boat well hold on does that mean if
people wear the shirt they'll get high
yeah go for it a big big whip definitely
that's what the
police don't wear it if you're pregnant
that's a joke by the way the police say
that um if you're even in the same room
as a grain of fentanyl you just pass out
yeah you just instantly start foaming at
the mouth have a seizure that of course
is a
joke you'll be fine um I made a little
video on our socials like talking
through the collection but in case
people haven't watched it there's a fun
little detail in the Hang tag of this
collection there's a guitar pick oh um
because yeah because Trixie plays guitar
it comes with a guitar pick yeah where
it's h part of the Hang tag I don't know
oh it's part of the Hang
tag oh that's sick that's cool yeah wait
I do want to show that that's really
cool I don't know if you will see it cuz
where's your video you have on it on
Instagram onr Teddy fresh Teddy Tenny
Ranch Tenny franch Instagram this Dell
laptop little long if you guys see me
type in like a it's cuz this
dumbass Dell got like the tiny backspace
you know what I mean you need a big
juicy back tiny back space the space bar
is Tiny everything is Tiny I can't go
from one format to the other are you
saying you want an apple no I'm saying
this Dell sucks that's first and
foremost what I'm saying saying I mean
with a name like Dell I don't know I
agree really hate that name they used
they used to have these commercials yo I
got a Dell but now it's like yo I got it
was dude dude dude you're getting a Dell
you're getting a Dell that was it it's
like a punishment now dude so wait
where's the H tag so the video is right
there but uh it's a little long I don't
know if you can I skip forward I don't
know of Teddy fresh and I want to walk
you through our new collection with
Trixie her style Instagram is either
blasting loud or
muted I turned it down and so it was
just like the perfect marriage so I'm
going to start out actually with my
favorite dress watch we've been talking
about it a
lot but yeah it comes with a pick just
just believe us okay make a word for it
yeah unfortunately it does not come with
a little bag maybe we have a sample
right there I can go look okay yeah true
true we do work there
um let's see now just to touch on the
streames because this has been an
ongoing uh debate in you know amongst
the community amongst here in the
office now we we are planning on going
nobody's gotten sick we're planning on
going everything's good but there's just
a little things that are making me still
question if I'm going to do this you
guys the first one is when you look at
their promo material M the thumbnail
hold the
phone fire right streamy
Awards
thumbnail they already made the event oh
J one second chedy what my TV
again oh we're Skeleton Crew Dan had to
run and do something no Hank
tag are we good Dan what happened yeah
your screen froze is it still frozen
yeah it's just gone completely did the
HMI get kicked out a little bit can you
make sure it's I can Jiggle
It yeah I see it on the
TV and yeah every everything works on
the TV so as you can see this is their
thumbnail for the official event okay I
got it and IND this is J Shetty
why do they care about
him why do they care about this man you
know we to his pages to look at his
numbers they're not good they're not
even good right but he has the A1
smoothie so you know the air one
smoothie yeah it was so good it's so
good dude so good why does he even get
his own smoothie like who are you yeah I
think we need to work on a smoothie wait
there was there's a legit a YouTuber I
forget which one to get that kind of
respect you know we'll never have that
kind of respect and I don't know why J
shett there's J shett exposed videos why
yeah hold on let me see I forget who did
it but it was some oh was de it was
DeAngelo Wallace bro our boy friend of
the show what serious business three
years ago is it a joke or is it serious
this motivational quote page is run by a
scammer J shett whoa dude you know
D'Angelo speaks only in
facts only in facts
H let's
see let's go to the comments I'm just
spitting facts you know as an Indian I
can tell you this man has based his
entire philosophy and teachings from
surface level Indian philosophy taught
to
children I never disliked him I just
thought all his stuff was fake deep but
I'm glad someone finally talked about it
I think it's time to start talking about
J shett again but fake deep is not
scamming it's not a scam you're right
but he says scammer and he only speaks
in facts is is it still up Dan oh
okay um so again J shed's in the
thumbnail this is a problem for me only
because it implies that you know he's
going to sweep the awards he's nominated
for the biggest Award of the night
creator of the year yeah oh for what I
don't know in fact I think all those
people are that's just that's all the
creator of the year nomin are you no
well I know Mr Beast is nominated I
don't know who um I don't know who all
these people are Dylan
waney right I recognize her and I don't
know the guy in the
back so here's another thing now I like
Matt Pat he's a nice guy I've met him
yeah we met him a long time ago but it
was nice very sweet guy no red flags
very very you know how we met some
people and it was like immediate red
flags just from saying hi to them like
duri like dub
yeah just frantically freaking out
trying to like get a good thumbnail yeah
he's like yelling at people
yeah that you don't get on top Hey
listen you don't get to own two of your
friends eyeballs without that
hustle he's got him in a jar with foral
hiide somewhere in his room but here
this is not the worst thing now now okay
Matt Pat posted this video I need your
help I need you to throw someone out of
an award show live in real time this
Sunday August 27th at 6:00 p.m. Pacific
time I'm hosting the streamy Awards
right here on Game Theory now if you
don't know what the streamy awards are
they're basically the biggest award no
if you don't
know excuse me show digital video and
they have all of your what I can't I'm
just doing a little goofing I said he's
nice what what more does he want for me
well let's see
you I don't want to host bro they asked
us to present I said no I'm not
presenting you know what I mean like
let's let's slow it down a little bit
streamy
Markiplier markk robber quacky Jaden
animation stupendium dream Jarvis
Johnson like it is a huge list but
here's the point I'm hosting and that
means that I've got myself some chaos
plan for all the people that are going
to be in that room I've seen this whole
thing around the past present and future
of online video that means there's going
to be some nostalgic cameos there's
going to be tons of feels but there's
also going to be plenty of unexpected
twists there's going to be horror
there's going to be challenges I'm going
to force everyone in that room to do an
ARG in real time by ripping apart the
facility that is not a joke either but
perhaps coolest of all you have the
chance to impact the show in true live
stream fashion I'm actually giving you
the chance to vote in real time to eject
someone out of that ceremony Among Us
style okay this is I thought I was going
to like a prestigious award show not
some where they're
going to be playing Among Us I'm going
to accept my award seiest night for the
best podcast this is I thought what is
this supposed to be the Academy Awards
or YouTube or is this chuckecheese what
the is this I somewhere
between and it's perfect and it's going
to be perfect I'm not playing among us
because you know what everybody is going
to vote for me and then I got to play
along like I'm not there to play along
don't you want to leave get out yeah
wait why don't you just Lobby to win
refuse to move go around be like hey
what's up I'm Ethan vote for me because
I'm not playing games bro I'm the the
win only you know what I mean I'm a
guest member I said no when they asked
me if I wanted to present said no and I
meant
it I'm not doing this Among Us Goofs the
child I'm here as an adult to win
an adult award Chad is saying a ja
Shetty that's kind of
fun that is funny that is kind of
fun let's do that we
should we should we should have ja
turned on that one quick like wait a
minute actually awesome because I know
everybody doesn't like me and so like
basically oh so you're just I I see I
see thank you AB but I mean like the
general populace of these kinds of
things right eject Ethan he's a dick we
hate him obvious he used to be
fat the the ejecting is going to be like
a two second like you're not actually
being removed does matter I'm not
playing
long then just don't I'm not standing up
you just I'm not playing this I'm
not breaking stuff either I'm there this
is supposed to be prestigious night no
yes you think that at the Academy Awards
they going to be playing Among Us
they're going to be playing a duck duck
goose at the Academy Awards I mean no I
guess people there have dignity they
have class it's a prestigious
moment that's why I've never with
the streames because of this and
because of the shety
well we're going to go and we'll
see how you feel about it after
if they kick me out I'm
leaving no coming back I'm taking I'm
taking I'm leaving and you can get aide
home or you can come with
me man a joke
man leav my friendships behind exactly
people said I don't blame you Ethan all
right let's do another poll then oh no
should I participate in this
childish
you know because let's be real
I'm a dead serious
guy and I would hope that they would
take this award show more seriously
since I've agreed to
repend okay Cam makes a good point said
at the Oscars people are being slapped
in the face
right yeah also they're like up
they're reading the you know what you
well I'll tell you what if Jay shett
wins podcast he's going to be getting
slapped in the face oh man and then he's
going to be like what's the deal with
your he's gonna be like your wife's ugly
and I'll be keep my wife's name out your
mouth I'm going to
okay no I'm not going to there will be
no physical violence
no um are you doing the poll Dan and
like seriously don't do some stupid
like what do you mean exactly I knew
exactly you're going to do should I
participate in this childish
yep absolutely have fun no be a Los or
hater stay at home okay that's fine
that's that's a that's a good PLL yeah
that is fine I vot I'm fine with that
framing actually no be a loser hater
stay at home okay you guys still want me
to
go even
despite this humiliating childish
Endeavor which I'm clearly above I'm
going to have to hit you with something
pretty brutal right now give me a second
I'm going to have to pull out the trump
card stand by the audience just Trump
carded me 82%
yes okay all right the decision is made
we are going we're going to have
fun f n
Fun so it's at Sunday at 6 p.m. or was
it I don't know the time somewhere on
the calendar don't expect to see me on
the stage either they're not even I
guarantee they're going to do it during
a commercial and shed's going to win
during a commercial break do we leave if
that happens can we leave can we storm
out um if shedy wins during a commercial
break because that's the tri that's the
Perfection of
disrespect are you walking out with me
Dan if Shetty wins during the commercial
no I'm applaud I am fully behind Shetty
I I hope he wins Dan's trying to get a
job I'll walk out with you Ethan you
better hope that Shetty doesn't pay
those Darman rates then Dan your ass be
making like minimum wage over there we
we should bring those leftovers tomato
plushies I like I like that all right if
you guys are watching please vote for
Shetty then to get ejected that is funny
cuz he's supposed to be like the guru
that everyone loves no get out if we
could get the FAA Troopers to get out to
tip the scales on that it would be
pretty funny There It Is guys all right
if you guys vote for shett I'll go I'll
go ah somebody posted such they pulled
such a good receipt on you from an old
video and I'm having trouble finding it
does anybody know what I'm talking about
did anybody see this on the subreddit I
do I'll go look for it right now I know
EXA I don't know what you're talking
about I'm pretty sure I found it and
erased it whatever you're talking no I'm
I haven't seen it I haven't seen
it um okay so we're going and other
exciting news we're going whale watching
without the hurricane they let us res
schedule y
so I got to do stuff on both days wants
to complain I got to do stuff on both
days yes it's called the weekend it be a
shame if you caught a cold whale
watching man it'd be a shame you know oh
my God it it's windy it's cold out there
on the ocean man also you could there's
a lot of sun you can't escape maybe sun
stroke maybe get sun poisoning man you
know uhuh you could go overboard what if
I just get lost at se yeah then I really
nobody can say anything sorry guys I got
lost at C that night mhm become friends
go thank you Cam is that it then that is
it I don't know why I couldn't find
that old video let's go this is the
receipts Here Comes oh no no no I saw
this and I immediately clicked off it I
was like no no no no I'm not I say no
I'm not I I know what you're trying to
do and I'm not watching play it play it
roll it not okay I'm not talking about
the streamy these two things that I
really didn't want to do but I forced
myself to do changed the course of my
life like completely and forever and in
my life since then like I I always look
at these opportunities of things that I
don't want to do as like what is it
worth these moments of awkwardness of
Uncertain full screen it maybe full
screen okay of discomfort for the
potential that it holds dude that's
talking about like going to the stream
is not a risk
this is the motivational speaker we all
need not shed
true true I'll take shed's award I'm
everything Shetty wish you really
love I'm the real deal all right thank
you guys we're going to go I said I'm
going to
go I've tried everything you really have
he actually has and still
is but I'm doing it for you guys just
remember you owe me big time Heather
just donated $20 and said E's going to
come out with the diagnosis on the day
of the streames you'll find out you have
the you'll actually find out you have
Lupus that day you're like I can't go
got lupus I'm having a bad Lupus Day you
guys uh what is this is just the link my
live you we saw it Oh there's a nice
blur about the Holocaust
here that's nice sorry because it's the
how it's we met in the Holocaust Museum
oh it's like it just Auto does that yeah
it just gives us a nice little blurb
systematic state sponsored killing of 6
million
Jews mhm good times thank you for
cutting off that music before this is
supposed to be a heartwarming Story
YouTube all right death to all Jews
that's that's up crazy so I
actually do can we watch the the
D'Angelo Wallace video legit like I'm
curious I want the dirt on on maybe
since somebody should first watch it off
air it's D'Angelo Wallace he crushes
just an old video we are maybe going to
like meet him yeah we may 48 hours just
maybe he's going to put out his hand on
be
[Laughter]
like there actually you know what there
was a really good meme from the
subreddit about my relationship with J
shett yeah you should pull that up I
know what you're talking about and I am
being of course silly about this whole
thing just so you guys know nobody
actually thinks that I genuinely go to
bed thinking about J shett although I do
generally he's the first thing I think
about when I wake up oh
yeah this is me and Jay
shett it's like Flanders and Homer kind
of yeah yeah this is Ethan's beef with J
shett dinkle
bird if this is where I'd put my streamy
if this is where I put my streamy if I
had
one be afraid of me Shetty when I went
that streamy it's all over for you buddy
your Empire is going to come crumbling
down when your people who look to you
for inspiration for strength for
guidance see
me taking the award from your Guru on
stage besting him humiliating him in a
competition of who makes the best
content me mhm I'll look down on my
defeated enemy
and I'll pierce his beautiful eyes with
a gaze that says it all it says
shett
done guess what I'm the new
Guru I'm doing a collab with I'm doing a
I'm doing a collab with Steve Robbins
Tony
Robbins Tony
Robbins Who's d I'm doing a
collaboration with Toren Robins you're
done
also I'm making a collab with DAR man
I'm taking them
all and I'll make it a smoothie
dude and it's going to be the color of
your
eyes all right come on let's move on
sounds nice yeah it will taste good
obviously be your secret
lover what
uh let's move down the list here what do
we got Ethan when he goes live on
Tuesday very funny
guys everybody's making fun of you today
I live at
30 my name is Walter Hartwell White I
live at 308 Negra Royal Lane Albuquerque
New Mexico
87104 that's funny that's funny that is
funny oh my
god there that is I don't understand
this one you guys are going to have to
explain it to me I also asked Eli I said
do you understand this I love Alfredo
don't get me wrong he's my
boy uh but this got a lot of
points it says does anyone else think
Alfredo looks like Ethan in this
picture yes yep really I don't see
it well there's another one where they
found a picture side by side with him is
it the same post is it a gallery can you
uh this photo is really funny of Alfredo
though it's so good he's just like such
a little shrimp I took it yesterday
during left TR this was right this was
right after the incident there is a next
photo moment later oh look how cute I
am this I don't see that I do not see it
you guys are
crazy okay well there's there's somebody
else that he very much looks like and
this one blew my mind uh AB just sent it
in the Discord mhm Alfredo looks like
okay that's interesting the dragon from
the never- Ending Story
falor That's yeah whoa that's show me
falor there's a link to falor falor in
the duck oh wow he does look like falor
dude that's sick then we have our own
falor all right can you just drop it cuz
just too much yeah move around here yeah
the reason I took that photo was cuz he
was he was just standing in your lap
looking at me for like 10 minutes
straight like that just like that here's
falor here's Al fluo oh yeah I see I can
see that that's a good vibe yeah you fro
I know it was you FR I like that I used
to love this movie when I was a kid me
too it was scary I just remember he went
in that room and there was like ice and
lasers and H did that happen in
that movie I don't even remember but I
remember loving it I have a confession I
didn't see it until I was like quite a
bit older saw it when I was like I don't
know 17 or something just like randomly
to go back and watch it it did okay this
is the original photo by the way yeah
that this all came from he just stand
Standing looking at me for literally 10
minutes so they had just gotten a beef
with Ka and he was on timeout right so
he was cooling off looks like he's
really learned his lesson yeah he's he's
thinking about things but he's done
he'll do that very often just stand like
far away and look at you it's the cutest
thing ever oh my God so you guys think
I'm cute but not like in a nice way like
in a dog not like a human way like in a
dog way yeah got
it in a dog way well how else am I
supposed to take you look like a
dog I didn't my a dog man people say
that about me all the time so oh yeah
other people are saying the movie is
scary I don't remember being scary for
kids it's pretty scary I
thought yeah it was spooky C he's got he
I don't remember
exactly let me hit this Sigma
brain skull is expanding my dude I'm
really curious what people think about
this it's really so
good yeah I guess it should be like
obvious it's very good it should be said
like hopefully you like spicy stuff it's
it's a it's very subtle I mean it's not
it's subtle but like some people are far
more sensitive to it than others so I
don't know it just just be warned I
believe that if you don't like spicy
food you'll still like this 100% yes
yeah it's just a little tickle in the
throat it's incredibly subtle yeah and
it's doesn't stay with you either you
know what I mean why the is this so
small I wanted to watch this video what
the hell is this
that's a 300 lb block
what what
what happened I don't know what is this
tick wait Tik Tok I got to zoom in okay
I mean that works kind of 1600b box so
low quality was it originally that low
quality no original hold on uh you might
be able to find this on YouTube it's I
I've seen it before so this
guy is so freaking cool I want to
celebrate him he's a uh retired
Construction worker okay and in his
retirement his hobby is trying to figure
out exactly how ancient Egyptians and
other ancient Architects built what they
did like Stonehedge and the pyramids and
you still have knuckleheaded
morons like Joe Rogan even recently
talking about how nobody knows how the
pyramids were built that they must have
been built by aliens which is so dumb
people have known how the pyram have
been built basically for like 100 years
M and this one dude one dude with some
free time and some smarts
proves really it's he's so cool uh you
guys are going to love this if you
haven't seen it I just think it's so
cool and it it just goes to show that
like everything that you don't
immediately understand it's it usually
has just it's always explainable you
know look how and don't you know what
else it's easy this guy makes it look
easy W he lifts like a hundred ton block
by himself man these with these very
clever Contraptions using primitive
tools too you he's the man dude the man
dude oh we found okay perfect we found
the it's from the History Channel I'm
reading so might did Mega claimed oh
wait this this one's only 42 seconds all
right I'll just zoom in on this but
it might get claimed cuz it's from the
History Channel I don't know think this
Tik tok's going to get claimed did
anybody did anybody check I re I reup
the Tik Tok there was no claim thank you
Zach Legend is the reup
watchable uh it's basically the same
thing okay let's just zoom in but you
guys are going to get get the idea from
it but yeah he's the man next time
you're your weird Uncle tries to tell
you the the aliens built the Pyramid
send them this
video a 300 lb
block this a 1600 lb block not too 300
lb block he moved like a pebble yeah
300 he's a retired construction worker
whose passion is moving heavy items he's
building his own Stone Henge in his
Flint Michigan backyard to prove it
Wally wallington's not a scientist but
he knows a thing or two about moving
rocks this is my first Stonehenge Arch I
permanent put in place uh is three
blocks way over a ton each simp my
explanation for this to move a block
about the weight of a minivan would be
to place a stone underneath it and once
I balance on it I can spin
it crazy of course with that spin you've
seen I didn't go anywhere but I got two
handles on my lever and I could place
another Stone on this side now every
time I spin a half rotation on each
Stone I move the block horizontally the
distance between the St
for my own output I could move a 1on
block 300 ft per hour he looked at me
damn So Co when you think about ancient
Egypt they had a mill like I don't know
if a million hundreds of thousands of
slaves doing it all day every day MH you
you you would def you could EAS I mean
not I don't know easily but you could
definitely build the pyramids and
there's lots of smart people back then
they were doing all kinds of advanced
mathematics they were real smart people
back then figuring crazy out you
know that's really cool je he gets CRA I
sure let's you know next thing you know
it's 300 ft in the other direction on
another piece of property it can move
bonds he's like he's trying to always
outdo himself and move something heavier
he's like can I move your barn betting
he'll put one of his theories to the
test and try to stand this 199,200 lb
block by himself in order to move it up
to this point I just rock the block back
and forth adding weight to that end and
that opens a gap on this side and just
slide a board
in then I add to waight to that end
there it goes it's just and Slide the
board in on this end this Shoring box
acts like a jack slowly raising the
block
huh imagine how efficient that would be
if to have like 10 people you'd be able
to do that so fast yeah yeah right
that's why I love this this man
single-handedly just fisted Joe Rogan
yeah we love that he's so
cool he does this man doesn't need Alpha
Brain you know what I mean he needs what
he needs is Sigma brain fix him up by
going to Gamers subs. you know he
doesn't sit there like an idiot and just
talk about like oh dude the aliens
nobody knows how it was built no he goes
out there he figures it out that's what
a real man does Joe
Rogan you know that gets my dick heart
this I I didn't notice the
difference this is not okay you guys
what is this a why are we looking at
this I look cute I just hi hi girl I
love
you so
cute all right this last part is
incredible I just start spr the sand the
sand will wash out and the block will
start coming
down once the sand is washed from the
pit the Block's own weight slowly stands
it
up okay finally she's between the lines
guys
wow that's so cool so they you know what
I mean
like these guys are just bozos don't let
them talk any any to you
seriously what's this guy's name so I
can shout him out so you guys know what
to look for
let me see this video is going to come
in useful for some of you guys I know
for sure this is
um forgotten
technology probably just
to uh the Forgotten
technology it's a Spanish
upload I know if you just Google dude
building pyramid Vine you'll figure it
out thank you he's from Michigan
apparently has it been 30 minutes it has
it's been in uh 42 minutes as a matter
of fact so let's talk about our gamer
sub offer here for you guys this is our
new flavor as we touched on in the
beginning Sigma brain
na yep oh busting classic song dude I
mean the process was essentially we
pitched them like a few highlevel ideas
for flavors we started from there and
then kind of picked the one that we like
the best and
then nailed it down we toned in on the
spicy Margarita fairly quickly from what
I remember it was it was the superior uh
option and you know we took our time too
we did a lot of rounds of
testing
little really perfected it see if yours
taste to there was one uh there was one
other option we were thinking about and
and they told us it would taste horrible
do you remember what it was oh it was
Cola that's right they were like yeaha
baked Cola taste is just not good which
I get yeah I can see that
yeah yeah we worked on this for months
and uh they put it in the they they
finalized it put it in production and
it's here man God I love it it's so good
go to gamersupps.gg and use the code H3
to get 10% off your
order for how many 100 servings you guys
mhm 100 servings of Sigma brains mhm
that's a lot of brains guarantee per
serving it's a lot cheaper than Alpha
Brain and Alpha Brain is for losers and
doesn't have caffeine in it true as far
as I know apparently this has New
Tropics
too apparently Sigma Sigma Sigma
mindset so yeah I hope you guys will try
it out if you guys are into energy
drinks hydrating beverages if you're
trying to kick sugar and have a tasty
beverage this is going to help you do it
yeah or you can get caffeine free right
too if you need
that if you're pregnant a Mormon a
Christian a Christian uh scientist
Christian yeah or child shout out anyone
else Lutheran Lutheran Hindu Quaker
Buddhist Budd Buddhist don't drink
caffeine oh I'm sorry I I thought we
were just naming random religions no
those people don't do
drugs the Mormons they don't I don't
think they drink I I was just hopping on
and I don't know what I'm talking about
I will say it says if you're pregnant
nursing or considering pregnancy consult
healthc care professional prior to us in
this yeah cuz it has C just because I
said I mean you can consult your
doctor yeah I love it I hope you guys
try and let us know what you think I
hope you guys love it too I think you
will oh has a really good assortment of
vitamins yeah was vitamin C 100% vitamin
D 3 12 B6 150% B 12 4,00 billion per no
it says 4,000% vitamin H 300% I mean
it's off the charts here guys wow you're
going to be
buzzing buzzing off Sigma
brain so one more time Gamers subs. use
the code H3 you get 10% off your order
very exciting times my friends it's time
to gamer sub it
up
so how do people leave reviews of it
just do you have to like get it first do
you have to have an account do you need
to have received it first love uh I
don't usually leave reviews but yeah I
mean obviously you should try the
product try it for yourself and leave it
a rating you probably have to buy
somewhere between five stars I think you
have to be a verified purchase yeah yeah
oh my God and one yeah there it is guys
thank you everybody Sigma been waiting
for that
one
um Sigma let's
see I'm in a self doxing competition
with my mom not sure what's the
joke
oh what's the joke guys when Ethan is in
a self-d doxin competition and his
opponent is
Donna what is this supposed to tell me
that you're worried next cuz she's the
queen of
it we did have to button my mom we
button her twice within like 5 minutes
she's like I'm in this exact location
and then when we were I was you also had
like a button right at the beginning of
the show I saw that too yes there was
earliest button I don't remember why but
I think you just like kind of kind bad
word no it wasn't even that you just
like kind of you just stumbled over your
intro and you were just like that was
terrible I'm kind of yeah I just thought
it wasn't funny yeah or it was weird it
was just like a weird energy out the
gate and he was like let's just start
over and I like that for I thought maybe
you said like f you know like or
something in first 30 seconds that's
what I thought that would be useful
though yeah that would be good I
remember that uh shout out to my mom
yeah and then she was talking like mad
friends and then gave their exact
names where they live wait Zach did she
talk to your grandma is that happening
we need to set that up but uh I think
they they should play M together I that
could be yeah we need that does your
grandma call it m both my grandmothers
call it m okay so at what point when
during the aging process do you just
start loving
maang I think uh I'd say 56 just when
menopause hits yeah it's coming it's
it's kind of like you have to if you're
a Jewish uh
she tried showing us the rules and I was
like what I feel like I'm looking at the
Matrix it was like a long paper it's
pretty complicated game pretty
complicated I tried to figure it out
once and I was just like uh this is this
I played it one time last summer and it
took me a while but I got it but I don't
think I could play today I don't think I
could I think the trick is you need to
be retired to
have free space in your brain for that
we have like young fertile Minds and we
can't grasp it somehow these well it's
like I I don't have free space in my
brain right now to to memorize right
yeah you need the motivation too yeah
here here's the other freaky thing is
like my mom my my grandmother trying to
teach her did not understand once she
hit a certain age picked it up right
away I'm not you it's really
weird probably good for old
Minds though to keep on great they say
that um like reading is good it can it
can prevent um de or dementia cases of
dementia and stuff if you do like uh
Sudoko my mom always does the like
Crossroads cross words that's good on
her phone so as we get older fer
Troopers
remember maang you got to keep your
brain engaged soku probably frankly even
video games sure would keep your mind
fairly active and sure you know so
that's what I'll how old are you
dude when I retire I wonder if I'll
finally pick up video games when I'm
retired I don't know you'll have a lot
of time yeah cuz right now I feel like
I'll never get into it cuz like the time
commitment I wonder I don't think you
will I think you'll want to do something
else
still and I think you'll feel like I'm
too old for this
maybe I'll be playing with the grandkids
I'll be wiping the floor with them dude
um Ethan is already playing with Bruce
and Theodore it was so funny the other
day the three of them were sitting
together playing Mario Mario 64 and they
both Bruce and Teddy were both holding a
controller each and Bruce is already
saying Mario Mario when he wants to play
Mario and then they both have unplugged
PlayStation
controllers but Bruce Lu so serious and
he's holding it like he's actually
playing funny yeah it's cool they love
have you guys been to a Mario World yet
Universal yeah we went um the was a
little too small for most of it it and
then one ride was like a few hours wait
ride was 2 hours I was like that it
was already the end of the day for us
and we were just over it standing in
line with like a a three-year-old and
Bruce and or four-year-old and one and a
half hell no and Bruce is like so
Restless right now it's just not yeah
Teddy was like let's get in line I was
like you you don't even know what you're
saying
yeah you just you don't come close to
understanding what that means yeah it
was kind of a let down the main ride the
going into it was really cool the line
was awesome but the ride itself was
pretty lame oh how long did you
wait wait for probably an hour maybe
maybe a little under an hour yeah okay
how you feeling by the
way uh I'm I'm all right uh pretty much
the same Lena just it just hit Lena last
night like she was fine until last night
hit her like a bus yeah was bad last
night yeah and she just woke up it's
been like 12 hours 14 hours yeah wow I
wasting yeah you
know I feel like in the alpha uh Co that
there were some people that weren't
affected but I feel like now wherever we
are it doesn't really happen like that I
feel like everybody gets sick from it
from Co yeah there's no like oh I had it
but I didn't feel anything I think it's
still happening I just heard the a day
about somebody really
yeah they're me then they got it
me I guess they cuz somebody else
got it but if they didn't know to check
they would they never they got it yeah
it probably happens at Le me
right all right well I hope you guys
feel better thank you yeah you guys just
going to take it easy this weekend I
mean you can't go outside with Co right
yeah you can't go anywhere we watching a
Vander pump M we finally made it to the
end I forgot yeah we finished it we
finally finished it oh okay so skipped
where are you guys we skipped season two
yeah still early on it's crazy right
season one was nuts right yeah it's like
it's it seems fake but it's so funny
kind of like satire or something it's
fake it's not bro isn't fake it's not
fake Dan you have no clue what you're
talking about I I've seen a shitload of
it now it's fake it's not F bro these
people like they're being humiliated
publicly on a daily basis a lot of
people don't give a about that no
you're wrong Dan they're getting married
they're having kids this is not fake Dan
take it back it's not like entirely I'm
not saying it's entirely back okay all
right you're saying exaggerated yes and
and the and the fights are planned and
like they kind of know the flow yeah
fights are not planned watch it the
fights are stupid that's why I think
like maybe they're kind of like planned
but it it still makes it worth watching
it's still really entertaining I'm not
I'm not knocking the ENT payment value
you know what I me wrestling is real
dude yeah exactly it's real to exactly
that is s that is such a good comparison
it's real to me it's not the same no
it's not I truly believe that it's
mostly
real it's mostly real I can get behind
exaggeration but I cannot believe that
some of those arguments would be fake
that they're just like too real they I
here's what happens The Producers create
explosive sitations I can understand
that and they put themselves
intentionally in these situation cuz
they know they need to do it for the
show like oh this girl don't get along
let's send them on a girls trip and then
let's get understand that but that's not
fake but what's happening is still real
okay like how's that fake because the
people themselves in my opinion they
know they know they're on the camera
they know they're on a reality show they
know what gets them
airtime they lean into it fake means
plan you're right okay scripted well
some of it is scripted some of it
absolutely is scripted Loosely scripted
not like telling them exactly what
they're going to say but they know how
it's beats the producers have planned
beats like oh they're going to go to
Mexico oh then they're going to go do
this but that's not the perspective of
the show the show is just like we're
just we're just peeping in on the lives
of
these they don't hide that they they go
on they go on trips all the time they
don't hide it the show's involved in all
that somebody use the word in the
chat manufactured that's maybe better
than fake it
is for me it's like if it's manufa it's
like insane like the the episode we just
watched one of the characters got a
tattoo of his ex-girlfriend got her name
dude Jax is the best
he the Jax stsy Arc is one of the best
yeah it's like even real or fake like
the psych like the psychology behind
that so interesting to me even if he's
just doing it for entertainment it's
like why would they go this far God
somebody said Raquel did an interview
with Bethany Frankle the other day who's
Bethany Frankle Bethany is from the
Housewives of New York remember her oh
Bethany Bethany oh God I did an
interview with her so we finally watched
how did that go the big
Scandal and I have to say it it didn't
disappoint on paper I can see how you be
like it's not a big deal but knowing
everything it's psychotic it's psychotic
and then when you go to the reunion Tom
is such a freak let me just tell you one
thing that he said that blew my mind
so he was cheating on his girlfriend of
10 years for seven months with this girl
Rael Rael by the way was was trying was
trying to hook up with no it's not
spoiler not it is spoiler don't listen
if you are it's definitely spoiler
so wait hold on so I mean at this point
the whole world knows but if you guys
don't want to hear yeah I'm just going
I'm just going to say what he said then
I don't want to ruin it for
you so the girl during the reunion was
like oh well you were both of us
at the same
time which is up right he's
cheating and then he's going home and
he's having sex with a girlfriend and
then he says to her while he's trying to
apologize and tell how sorry is he goes
oh yeah you had your shirt on the whole
time so sexy and one of his complaints
about her is that the intimacy isn't
good and he doesn't enjoy having sex
with her I guess so he's like yeah we
did have sex but it wasn't even good cuz
you had your shirt
on it's hard it's it's hard to you had
to be there I guess yeah you had to
watch it you had to be there dude you
had to be there so bad you had to be
there you
guys it was
crazy but now what do we do now I guess
we got to watch um below deck and then
there's a new New York Housewives like
the whole cast is new and I kind of like
them I'm into it one of them was the CEO
I think of J crew for a long time so
she's super into
fashion nice and yeah is that the
lesbian girl yeah she seems cool yeah
yeah she's got good
fits um uh the other thing was so now
that I know the all the the juice now I
need to go watch Howe's interview with
Tom sandal and see how bad he botched
that but I like now knowing all
this I can cannot imagine wanting to
know Tom's side of the story like I
really don't he's a demon I don't need
to know his side of story and then so
Howard is in there without knowing
anything and trying to sympathize with
the devil yeah you know you're in there
trying to excuse the devil this doesn't
work like that Howie come on
man oh they're saying the Bethany
interview was just like hoe sendal
interview oh God why would Bethany do
that she's smarter than that apparently
not I thought at least well so Raquel is
also looking really bad to be honest in
this whole thing I is looking terrible
some people are saying that they think
Raquel looks okay in this I don't know
how no by the way you guys JX is coming
to this new show House of Villains I
cannot wait this is going to be my end
game when is
this yo when does this come out uh
October 12th I love ja snake it has Jack
it has uh
Tiffany and fisa from 90day October 12
it has beu New
York yeah oh my god do say Jack is
opening a bar now are you
serious he looks look at this
dork whoa we lost a lot of weight or
something what's with the specs nerd I
mean he wasn't like no he not that he
was overweight before but it looks a lot
like Slimmer no he wasn't overweight he
was jacked saying I guess he was just
jacked it looks a lot um
uh wait till you guys find out about
what happens with ja it's nuts dude it's
so weird like going through 10 seasons
so fast you get to see people age like
10 years over like just a couple of
weeks right man so anyway I'm glad you
guys are enjoying that you got plenty to
watch then yeah very good excited very
good yeah I ate up the first two seasons
man I was glued glued even the Third
season was really good too yeah all
right oh here we have
a oh they're saying we should watch um
Jack and Britney podcasts with Schwarz
oh
oh my God you know what I got to
say this I I like Schwarz and I feel bad
that he's catch caught so much stray
bullets because of his friend you know
what could he do he was
like yeah I don't know that I'm getting
two in the Weeds now fore for for most
of you guys what you're talking about
this point it's just I felt bad for
Schwarz you know like he got crushed
publicly his bar got review bombs the
thing that's like annoying about it is
that he was also good friends with
Ariana you know like he wasn't only
Tom's friend okay and so what was he
supposed to do like literally there was
no good situation the Middle look at the
end of the day it was it was Tom sandal
that put everybody in that horrible
situation was this the the business
partner yeah okay they open a bar
together yeah I like like I've explained
I like dip in and out so like I I know
that they he has a bar at some point he
has it's ruined right like they have
like a 1.2 on Yelp now like it's
absolutely screwed their business man oh
boy oh Schwarz follows Teddy fresh
somebody said what Schwarz is a cheater
well they're all cheaters not world's
colliding right now Schwarz is gross H
come on you guys give him a break he
just kind of like Schwarz knew what he
did oh my godz is the worst Jesus all
right I think the problem is that he
just doesn't stand up for anything I
don't know no Schwarz is a scumbag for
what he did to Katie always cheating
that's true he did cheat no everybody in
this group is a cheater it's crazy they
all cheat yeah I think Katie's the only
one only one I think I'm desensitized to
the cheating cuz they're all such like
horrible cheaters yeah wow a lot of hate
for
Schwarz okay jeez all
right
sorry Schwarz Falls Teddy fresh I don't
know that's crazy I'd be like yo bro i'
really like to talk to you but my fans
are telling me that that I can't
associate with you
bro anyway moving on thank you to all of
the non uh initiated for uh watching
that putting up with that now our last
Teddy fris spokes person on the internet
was chapis not your ID
yeah and I can you might be able to say
that this is an upgrade of sorts okay
what do we got so here is the NPC styled
uh stream from Tik Tok and he is the
Gizzy
Master really as you can tell he's
wearing a Teddy fresh shirt which I love
to see and here is um give him a shout
out it just says
Jason probably need more info than that
to find him no wait unless he just has
the at Jason on Tik Tok Jason that's not
that's just the display name gotcha uh
well here he is the Gizzy Master we'll
find out his account info but so this is
our new spokesman enjoy than that ice
cream ice cream so good thank you the
ice cream thank you the heart me I H you
too thank you
thees 100 glizzies and dream Gizzy
Overdrive
[Applause]
what increasing grip by
7% oh my God what is this we are locked
in thank you for over 160 glizzies and
doing Gizzy
[Music]
overdrive think of that ice cream ice
cream so good think ice cream oh my God
I accept I accept you our Gizzy
Overlord as our one true spokes person I
pulled that sound bite at the end hit me
with
it that is such a powerful sound that's
pretty good man I got to say as all the
NPC people I found I got to give it up
to our Gizzy Jason over
here hit us up hot dog kind of sounds
good right now yo a hot you got you got
the Gizzy fever from that
thises and dozy overdrive yo give me a h
right now no
not okay I don't want
it oh man not that it's the little
picture of a hot dog there but it's he's
going viral on on Twitter okay cool 10
million views so thank you to let's go
Teddy fresh
Ambassador hit us up Jas um we'll hook
you up with some Teddy fresh is our new
Ambassador we should order though I'm
hungry and Ela needs a
glizz uh so you don't want Taco Bell you
want to get a Gizzy Factory yo you know
what Gizzy
Grill can I can you eat I don't think so
wait I don't think you're supposed to
eat hotg it's like processed meat
yeah I don't think you're supposed to
eat hotg let me look it up can I eat
hot hot dog while pregnant all right
Olivia yes all beef hot dogs are fine to
eat while pregnant but they must be
cooked thoroughly well of course who's
out here eating raw
dogs I thought that okay hold on let me
read a couple more sources if you're
pregnant and need a hot dog like your
life depends on it Ela that's what
happens when you get a craving it's like
your life depends on it thoroughly
cooked all beef hot dogs are the best
option okay can I get a uh can I get a a
a rare Hot Dog please medium rare Hot
Dog if you want to die that's how you
order it so then Sam is usually our
we're missing a Point person you want to
take the point on the order on the uh
well I don't know who else can do it
there's there's not that many of us I
have
this nails and I feel handicapped by the
way I wanted to comment how cool these
are yeah so this girl on Instagram she
made these for me it's for the teddy
fresh collab yeah and so so I don't know
if we want to show a closeup I I'll post
it tomorrow on my Instagram also the
vest looks really cool on you too um
could you I don't have a super easy way
to get a closeup but maybe can you take
a picture oh and then send it in
WhatsApp and I can pull it up yes
sir yes sir here can you take it
yeah now put that phone down wait
different perspectives here I'm come up
well I need different perspective a
different perspective put your phone
down
up now we
need oh no you found a new weakness for
me Z that's going to make me laugh no
matter what's going on it's so versatile
dude like I feel like we using anything
different perspectives you
guys stop we're going to not now when
we're going to hit a hot dog that's what
I'm going do to it all beef cooked
thoroughly what can I say Jason's
inspired me oh J he's the pro at it dud
yeah he's the man I I got to give it up
I got to give it
up all right so
um it's time to
play our Game guest the baby
picture that's right everybody welcome
to the show album today's host baby face
Ean Klein here some say I look like Al
fro some say I look like uh Grace that
one serial killer Gracie his name John
Wayne gy John John Wayne gayy all right
Macy Gray big difference we've got a
gallery of baby pictures from everyone
in the crew and the game is we are going
to try to guess which baby is which crew
member all right all right are you ready
to
play Guess the baby picture
all right coming right up here first
contestant oh this is harder than I
thought I don't know who this is oh wow
I have no idea oh you were talking all
this sh there's one picture per person
right uh I believe so because Ian can
you confirm that okay okay so our first
contestant is this beautiful blue-eyed
baby uh let me find a way to open this
Open Image new tab who is this beautiful
blue-eyed baby out on the beach
enjoying now here's my first my first
hint about this I have a feeling now
when pictures of me at this age look old
as this looks like it was a modern
photo which make makes me think it's got
to be one of the younger crew members
which would include Olivia and
love Sam right Sam is Sam how old are
you is Sam here I haven't seen uh I
don't think is here I think she she's
not here but she's she's 25 yeah 25
so my guess immediately was
Sam I think it's okay I'm trying to
triang triangulate the
face I'm feeling that it's
Olivia and that that also jives with the
quality of the photo it's too good the
photo quality is too good what do you
guys at home think a lot of Dan thing it
could be well no Dan's too old if baby
picture of him would be up
looking like mine the point that's a
good point I get I get what you're
saying yeah it's got to be oh yeah let's
do a poll everybody at home get your
vote in who is this baby doing a poll
okay start a poll who is this baby yeah
what are what are the options uh well so
just the blue-eyed people I guess Olivia
you have do you have blue eyes Olivia no
iown she has hazel eyes but sometimes
that changes changes yeah not at that
age blue eyes like that is it really
blue I can't tell from here let's zoom
in let's zoom in on this baby enhance
those are Blues pretty BL so wait dan
has beautiful Blues like that
yeah who else has beautiful Blues love
love has blue eyes love love has
beautiful Blues so it's got to be love
it's love I see it it's love yeah I do
see love now and also that drives with
the my photo Theory love you it doesn't
look like Sweden it doesn't look like
Sweden that's the trick you're trying to
Sweden it's on a vacation somewhere nice
try um do you still want me to do the
poll or are you confident with your uh
well let's let's do the poll I mean well
it's just you and love that Blues
beautiful Blues isn't it Sam has blue
eyes Sam has Blues beautiful Blues so do
them then or is her what color are Sam's
eyes yeah she has blue eyes okay then
yeah let's do Sam love and yeah Sam
love Dan I unlike you guys have
beautiful hazel eyes which I personally
find to be more
interesting beautiful Blues no they're
Hazel blue we discussed this a couple
weeks ago on the show and they're more
blue so I'm saying it's love based on
the quality of the photo and the
Beautiful blues and now that I'm looking
at it I feel like I see love me too I
see love people are torn though most say
it's love but in second place is dance
interesting interesting um so we have
this uh neat little uh graphic so we can
find these babies
he all right some love huh who is that
baby we should reveal at the
end reveal at the end reveal at the end
after you make all your guesses yeah cuz
you might make some changes did as we go
along okay okay sure okay okay okay all
right so we got this baby here beautiful
baby
I sent the pictures in the WhatsApp but
I'm assuming you need it in Discord I uh
no no I'm I got it do you have um
Postmates
love this guy you do the company one
though you have the compy I have the
company card I can just give it to him
if you want order something uh then sent
a place that we can order
from oh that looks good what the this
this don't this place is name don't say
the name but this place is crazy
good dud okay this is what I want this
is it oh I see you have it on the so
type type your type what you want and
we'll get it okay so let me pull up the
one so we can I didn't I'll look at it
in a sec now who is this baby here okay
this is a baby
baby and here we have what appears to
be beautiful blues again now this is the
age where it can change yeah that's the
age where you can't tell
anything but those are beautiful Blues
who is that baby who's that baby I see
they've got the eled head going on get
that changes too that doesn't mean
anything got the cone head baby a
[Music]
funny Olivia is about to cry over here I
do think they are beautiful Blues though
baby how
small is that perhaps baby
want or could it be Dan Dan again I
think it doesn't look old enough cuz
Dan's old as
I mean like me this could be it no
I guess I guess yeah I thinking this
could be Samantha H and I do believe
that this Baby's blue eyes translated
into
adulthood young
adulthood so um essentially it's it's
got to be either Sam or love in my
opinion if you if you consider the blue
eye
Factor uh so let's throw it I guess is
it Sam or is it wait love we already
picked well maybe so it's Sam it's Sam I
saw Sam when yeah it's got to be Sam
first pulled it up gotta be who's Sam
you want to make that the call yeah
that's our final okay love you can go
ahead and shift that baby into the Sam
category there she goes okay oh
interesting now this is an interesting
one and I'll tell tell you why this
person is
old whoever this is is an old
got to be pushing 30 at
least you can tell you know you can tell
thank you yeah the seaing hairline or
something the hair is beautiful
beautiful blonde
hair
jeez who could that it's kind of hard
with the kind of faded desaturated it
could be blonde but it could also be
like kind of strawberry or even Brown
like light brown to be honest very light
I mean that could also change from that
age the hair texture and
color who is this
baby huh who's that yeah I am thinking
potentially it's cam cuz he's a bit
older I don't believe it's
Dan who's the
oldest so you think that blonde baby is
me I don't know the hair changes like I
said I'm sure it's not then cuz it could
be well how old are you
Cam I'm 29
29 and dad you're like what 30 I'm like
43 same age as
you this looks like a 43y old's baby
pig I mean who else is even close in
age it doesn't look like Dan but well ab
ab
is AB is the next oldest I'm 31 yeah 31
dude you're
old wait that could be a wait what about
you Lena I'm
29 you still got so young
got enjoy you're basically still a baby
please yeah enjoy your life you have so
much to live
for I sent my order I mean it could be
Lena but no maybe it's AB you
think I could see that you know I could
see it makes more sense than Cam and I
just don't think it's I don't think it's
Dan and ab is an old 31 geez
cringe you walk around at that
age not this weekend I think it's
AB we going AB is there a lot of ab in
the chat I think so let's see I'm seeing
I'm seeing I'm seeing Ian a decent
amount in here and we haven't really
considered Ian hold on Ian's kind too
Ian how old are you Ian's 29 as well I
believe right no that is correct ab's
31 old as C cam is 29 I said you
know what I could it could be Ian G whiz
man G whiz will let's do a poll it's
going to be either AB cam Ian
AB cam I think th it's those three right
were the ones that you were honing in on
oh this is a dog place so you got your
dream fulfilled yeah oh they only have
dogs that's what I'm saying sir they
have good vegetarian ones they do oh and
look they have raw dogs so you can
actually eat a raw hot dog if you
want that's
exciting uh the
pole is leaning a although Ian's getting
a good amount of support to not much
cams Cam's down at
11 uh Ian is rising yeah ah man I I feel
like it's leaning AB though I feel like
I do if I see anybody's face in that
it's more AB me too than Ian's not an
English baby like the angle what it's
not an English baby I don't know what
that means but they're just they're just
smug you can tell the angle where AB was
right now in camera it really looks like
like that picture I think that's AB I'm
going to say it's ab and thank you
everybody for uh for your participation
on this very close though very
close Okay so we're going with AB over
there okay okay okay very good all right
rolling right along up
next we have another baby wow wow
wow wow wow wow
wow here's a
baby who is this
child this happy little child with a
giant balloon who is this child
H she's got also beautiful
Blues old old picture it is is an old
picture right so this person I don't
want to say is super old cuz
that'd be rude but cuz they're they're
they're young and beautiful yeah that
would be you would never say that right
God forbid but it that photo is a little
agan you know a little
aged agist it's a little agist people
are
saying I don't know I see some people
saying Olivia but the photo is so old
you
guys people are saying de not ELO I saw
people say well it's big blue eyes so
that would be
basically did we Peg Sam yet we
didn't um no you did wait we
did are we supposed to guess too people
are really conflicted on this one we
what the rules are we did guess Sam so
yeah you can say whatever you want I
mean I think that looks just like Ela
really yeah the the audience is quite
torn also you're being oddly polite
which makes me which makes me think that
maybe what way am I being oddly
polite I don't even know what you're
talking
about you're like this no not too old I
don't want to say well I can tell that
whoever's in this photo is going to
be whoever they are it doesn't matter
how old the photo is they're going to be
beautiful and
Youthful agess probably successful I
could see them as like a CEO or
something I don't know what you guys are
on about
right um it's elila I mean it's I
thought it was obvious cuz you're in the
thumbnail know it looks just like that
baby so that is Ela as a baby I've seen
so many photos of you as a baby that I
know there she is baby want baby want
are you wearing someone else's clothes
you told me you used to always do
that um this I can't tell this looks
like maybe maybe that was
mine okay I got the I'm getting the hot
Italian with hot peppers just just put
put in the chat what's double typ in
Discord no we're not actually ordering
here just type in Discord what does
double up mean though that's
hot actually don't know
know oh that's H you want me to type for
you but you can oh oh interesting so hot
oh okay you're right I see that I see
that do we like
sauerkraut do we like that not always
not really huh really kind of depends on
the situation yeah it kind of depends I
I I agree not always I'm typing for you
oh so I want this with um with these
okay with these toppings you got these
I'll I'll look yeah and then condiments
if you mark it in there I'll get
it yeah I got French fries for us to
share oh okay
cool so so if you guys want french fries
order for yourself I am not I definitely
will be because the fries here are bom I
got all the dipping sauce dude let's
go all right
next we are going up to our next
baby what a beautiful
baby wow this is a really weird photo H
it's so close this is the closest baby
closeup I've ever seen oh just opened
huge on my laptop it opened like this on
my
laptop who is this child oh who is this
child I don't know but he's making Lena
die laughing I feel like it's
Zach Zach but why is Olivia laughing so
much oh Olivia why are you laughing what
okay I open it was literally like
this I feel like I immediately know who
that is I immediately yeah I immediately
knew who it was okay hold on are you
guys going to say it no hold on let seeu
it let me see let me see oh who is this
child well I know it's not Lena cuz
she's guessing in AB ear yeah I was
going to
say
Olivia
why is that
funny Hey Olivia was cracking up when
you first opened this photo I don't
think it's Olivia but but Ela was
cracking up when her photo was on the
screen true true true
true you think that looks like
me kind
of I mean it could be cam oh maybe
that's Cam that's Cam that's
Cameron it's got to be it has to be
Cameron
it's got to
be people in the chat seem to agree
people think it's
cam you don't see Zach in there no it's
not Zach that's that's not a that's not
a Jewish
baby I can tell him when I see
him freshly
circumcised yeah you he wouldn't be so
happy in the I agree if it's not Zach
then I would go with Cam I see cam in it
I see it I see it I'm willing to just
slap a lot of people are saying e though
some people are saying Zach maybe we
should put throw to the PO let's do Zach
I feel like Ian's going to be such a
wild card we're just not going to guess
we're not going to pinpoint Ian for some
reason I'm going to know Ian when I see
him yeah yeah I'm going to know that
let's
[Music]
do cam Ian Zack cam okay there's this
answers are all over the place frankly I
know it's not Zach that is not
Zach
what is so funny
dude okay Cam is
overwhelming the polls here with 63% oh
wow so all right that's
that so okay oh can you get any mustard
too yo somebody just said uh oh actually
good timing on that we just got a $5
donation said damn you went full West
Coast on us mustard and sauerkraut is is
a classic you changed bro you used to be
a New Yorker this is crazy shaking my
head they're upset when was Dan a New
Yorker what no I'm talking about you oh
me they're talking about me no okay yeah
I said I like sourkraut mustard I need
mustard yeah at least you got the
mustard now mustard I got I got fresh
fro I got a large one fro you got to
tell me what you want this one okay oh
cuz I added it so I want the um and
check this out I want this large fry and
I wanted to get these what are you
showing
me hold on let me make you
big yo you got a double-sided lightsaber
it's actually sick
Bro this man is
[Music]
sick she just like oh
boy all right we got to make a call on
the on this baby here it's cam it's cam
saying cam yeah cam grants all right
there we go cam cam cam Cam Cameron
there he is what's
up wait get get a load of the baby
bottle there I got to go what look at
the baby bottle oh the baby bot it's the
sigma brain for the baby oh that's so
cute I can't see it as oh I'm sorry
right here let me we got such a
complicated thing there you go oh that's
fire there you go yeah this is totally
fine for
children sure
I mean when our son is born this is
going to be his first drink
yeah just to make sure he's running at
optimal it's kind of maob to think about
but what would happen to a baby who just
drank Sigma brain he turned into
Arnold Schwarzenegger bro it would not
do well it would not fare
well that that is not something I would
recommend to do oh I agree no what kind
of mustard do you want whole grain I
like yellow mustard yellow you can pick
two spicy brown maybe honey I like
yellow just yellow okay just yellow
that's the real
I'll get some sauerkraut too cuz
that guy humiliated me I'm not going to
eat it though oh okay I'll eat yours
just throw all right so get one
okay all right what do we got next here
who's that up next we
have this I know who this is instantly
huh now this is a Jewish Baby M
interesting right
[Music]
Zach do I know what I'm talking about
what the photo looks like it's from like
the 1970s dude how old are you Zach
except for the VCR I'm going to be 26
next month
so right and this child is a little
older so it would be closer but who else
has that dark of hair
you anti-emetic piece of I know a
Jewish baby when I see
one well cam has dark hair as does
Olivia and and Ian I mean like everybody
it's like black hair
dude but Cam's not Jewish no he's not
that's why it's not
him this is this is Zach all right
nobody else got an opinion on
that I mean I mean it's your call
ultimately oh I I I mean I think that
you know I I'm pretty sure I know
there's no shot that's Ian people are
saying that's Ian I are you serious that
is not Ian the thing is the the hair
color especially in like an old faded
photograph I don't know if you can trust
what your eyes you know that could be
much lighter than it appears in that
photograph no that's Zach okay let's see
what Ela thinks all she should be coming
back in a second I see a lot of Ian in
the chat should I
do Ian Z as the options if how could you
say that's
Ian um shame on you
guys just trying to trick me I don't
know the I mean the facial features you
can maybe see also he's got those Rosy
Cheeks like Zach has Zach you have Rosy
Cheeks right yeah look at the rosy
cheeks on this
child beautiful Rosy cheek maybe it's a
little my monitor's a little dark you
could have been you could have been
playing you know could have just had a
lot of sugar yeah hyped up I guess the
the Ian people are the silent uh but
loud because 77% are saying Zachary
silent silent but loud right that
doesn't make sense small but loud you're
right okay right so I think we well
let's see what Ela says okay Ela who is
this child who's that baby who is this
child
H oh my God show us wait dude
Zach you would you would you wouldn't
play that on anyone else I feel like
yeah that's really up that is
Zach it has to be I better be hold on
you're
getting getting pinned for that one Z
you said you would recognize a Jewish
baby yeah I think I'm getting Jewish
Vibes right that's immediately what I
said that's s and he just did the child
pornography thing so and it's he
already's got the beautiful hair show us
I said we show us I recognize your hair
Zach that's you yeah put them on Zach
it's Zach Zach it is get out of here
it's
Zach now was this before or after oh did
I ever talk about what your dad your dad
was trying to give me dirt on
you did I ever expose you or did was I I
didn't you didn't do you do should I not
say anything I'd appreciate it you did
there it
is Zach's dad I had the best orc with
Todd he was he was texting me all this
crazy super embarrassing on Zach
and he's like yo do this on the show and
I was like I don't think so that seems
kind of mean to his own
dad but you guys worked it out all right
so Zach so that one's going to Zach on
the far right there who is this give him
some gamer St oh my God I know who this
is I think oh oh my God I think I know
who this
is look at this there's such a
celebration I mean my goodness what a
dress wow what a dress that kind of
Celebration wow I have a feeling who it
is who who are you thinking Lena me too
and it's obvious that Lena's family
really loves her yeah
so unlike the rest of our un likee my
family but look how they celebrate her
that is a decorated baby yeah yeah
are you the oldest Lena no I'm in the
middle I'm number four of six four of
six I can really see Lena this it's
definitely crazy definitely question
most lookalike baby this is actually so
iconic though this outfit yeah it's so
little cupcake
baby we love this Lena we love it how do
you know it's me for sure um it looks
like you it does look like you the eyes
and like the eyebrows I can already
recognize also it just seems like your
family's really wholesome it seems like
from what AB talks about and this seems
like the kind of activity for a really
wholesome
family oh thanks but it does look like
you so that's
Lena there it is gamer Subs locking it
in who is this child oh I know who this
is I feel that I know who this is but
it's kind of uh a wild card I feel like
a little bit oh who is this
child who is this child I don't that's
not that's not one of us who that's not
one of us you think it's a you think
it's a it's a ringer I don't know decoy
it's a ringer I see
Olivia in the face you do mhm really I
do I see your face
there but you know my it could be
I think it's Olivia what do y'all think
I see it let's see what the chat says
what did it say on the foot Baby Gap
Yeah Baby Gap M definitely Olivia pretty
bougie I feel this
Gap the capap is bie no I mean I know
it's like that's like as middle of the
road as you can get right unless you're
rich all you buy is that what's that one
brand that cost like $3 Carters yeah
unless you're rich you buy Carters only
sure I I get that not Carter
specifically but I mean when I was
really young the Gap was definitely too
ritzy for my family but eventually we we
moved up to Gap level I was the same way
I bought a sweater from Gap and my
parents were P cuz I went shopping with
my sister and they gave us their credit
card mhm I actually it was that one
sweater that I love I love that sweater
my parents were pissed
bro my mom made a lot of my clothes when
I was a kid from the from that my mom
made a lot of clothes for me when I was
a kid oh my God people are saying Dan no
this is
Olivia I'm listening Olivia Hello
Olivia people are saying Dan
though you know what's throwing me off
about the Olivia thing though is that it
looks a little
old it's just a little grainy not really
grainy though it's it's just like an
could be like a night setting with flash
and it is night time Olivia it's a
pajama like it has the um the definition
is there yeah like if you zoom in yeah
it's not it's pretty detailed actually
mhm Carters is expensive dude what
Carters is like wait what or am I not
saying the name right cuz what I'm
saying is not expensive it's this like
everywhere in the world everyone buys
this it's like disposable baby
clothes it cost like a dollar no yeah
it's Carter how is Carter expensive
Carter is not expensive it's like $3
literally it's the most affordable
[Music]
stuff expensive I where do you get more
cheap than
that uh nobody has an opinion Let's do
let's on who this is yeah well I I mean
I'm pretty on board oliv I think Olivia
too yeah okay yeah eye shape yeah the
eye shape it is all right we're locking
it in we're locking it in
mhm
Olivia
Olivia make your gamer
Subs um wait is there a curveball of me
cuz I don't recogn is there one of me in
here uh no there's okay there's not one
there might be wait there might be a
baby Ethan who is this what old
picture that baby's
terrified this is not fair we cannot
tell anything from this picture this is
very young baby this is a very very
young this is like weak one
well are there some context clues
perhaps let's see win the Poo lots of
win the Poo
love mhm I mean that's in that could be
for either gender yeah the the clothing
is very neutral in color green crib no
pink on is kind of masculine kind of a
boy that's got to be a boy cuz
especially back then I think the crib
would have been more pink or something
back then you guys people were hardcore
with the colors mhm I think if it was a
girl it would have been more pink
therefore I believe that this has got to
be Ian as one of our last
yeah well there are uh
two uh crew members that have not been
picked yet and it's Ian and myself are
ones that you have not picked for oh no
it's got to be Dan cuz it's so old yeah
I was this is by far the oldest also
Dan's parents were writers on like
cartoons and and here's the cartoon
characters although that's a stretch to
be honest they didn't work on Wie the
Poo not far as uh my mom rote for Wie of
the poo Okay well you Jo yourself it's
then why you just do well he's got to be
objective yeah you said I don't think
they worked on that she did work on it
okay fine it's
Dan you can tell from that age Dan well
I have something else to throw in Dan's
father was into
photography that does not ex that does
not express a photo so I mean the photo
could would be would look higher quality
perhaps here's one of me from the sub
what's why you guys do this to
me what did I do I come out here every
day I entertain you guys and then this
is the thanks I get good what's the
problem this is not okay that is cursed
as can you imagine as poor little e
then I was so cute I was so lovable and
then you're like that's what I look like
crazy that you grew a beard so young so
weird that's a jump scare sometimes it
comes in early though I knew a guy in
sixth grade who already had like a
mustache and everything I knew that guy
yeah just the mustache
yeah all right that's Dan and then
finally calling that Dan wait who's left
Ian Ian's the last one left so I don't
know what the make of this
what but apparently it's Ian what that's
a sick ass baby right there dud oh my
God that's a cool baby look at that dum
baby this is one of us Ian do you have
beautiful Blues that's a golden baby
yeah you have beautiful Blues Ian yeah
you do that does not look like Ian at
all if this wasn't the last one I would
have no idea that this was the end this
is notan I could I was wrong about
knowing the English baby could this be
love it's too old the photo could you be
old I'm telling you this is an old
photo that's a sick ass baby right there
you loving this baby huh he's all about
it Zach's like damn this Baby's cool as
dude I don't know like it just
looks like kind of like blonde hair I
mean the baby has no
hair she's stubble given blonde I think
it's Ian I I think so I don't see Ian
here I think it's love love there's no
way that looks like Jack Jack from The
Incredibles let's or Ian I'm going Jack
Jack cuz if we if we say it's love
that's going to throw our whole game
yeah we we need to re assess reassess I
do a poll it's love or
Ian all saying that's love but then what
happened we this will be a disaster for
us I don't think it'll be that hard we
just look back but guys look how what
it's 90% love 85% love but look how old
it is the I feel like that's the first
time the audiences diverge from what you
were saying by a lot you know or maybe
it's like chalk marks on the background
and it looks like
grain or no that's grain or is it a
physical photo that has on it a physical
photo huh with Mark it has the
definition
mhm Jack Jack I can't unse it now so
wait if this is if this is love then
who's under love right now can you show
us yeah can we look uh yeah stand by let
me
uh there you see that
right that could be wait that's not love
that was the first baby we did mhm yeah
no remove that curse Ethan that's not
fair drink your Gamers sub his actual
photo is so cute
I command the cute I think there is an
Ethan later down in the album I think
okay uh I don't think so are we at the
end okay yeah I don't think
so I mean it was on the subreddit I just
I guess everybody knows there was other
ones that my parents sent you though I
think so I guess but she didn't we
should swap let's put love to Ian and
the new baby wait did we ever identify
Sam oh I guess we yeah we did we did I
feel good about that yeah this is the
last one can let me pull up a a a
closeup so you're making this this new
baby love and you're making and you're
just swapping that out for Ian yeah so
this one is really confusing yeah very
this one is not giving me Ian at all but
this is basically our only choice but
they have beautiful Blues which Ian
has that's right but I just don't see
Ian's face there do you all right not
really but funny but I feel like I got
to say something okay say something
please I I I I think Ian's trolling you
he doesn't have blue eyes does
he I don't know of course we switch to I
let me
see am I crazy open your eyes
bro yeah those are those are
hazel bro are those hazel eyes yeah when
he said it earlier I immediately was
like wait what you got to answer
truthfully man well I mean you've only
been looking in the for 6
years that was the impression I got is
that he was hurt that you have no idea
what I'm not your dad okay I'm not
gazing into your eyes I don't know I
don't know whose eye color is
what you know sorry now I know they're
brown we need to re-evaluate all of them
I feel like can I can I maybe throw
something in please why is that random
baby photo Dan the one that we chose for
Dan yeah the baby in the
crib let's look at that one again I'm so
confused now we got
to yeah hold on hold on let's let's pull
up the album let's put it here so we're
confused about this child at the top
which could be Dan it could be but it's
too new it's too new Dan's old yeah that
is that is okay okay so then we're going
does we're not we're not confused
about confused
about this is so funny this one and this
one these two babies here are
with me
uhhuh but that looks like Dan the dark
hair the receding hairline
right I don't know how much we should
interject but I feel like I know is that
a brown eye oh that baby has brown eyes
although again newborn yeah it's with
that newborn it definitely changes in
the beginning well go ahead AB
everybody's welcome too over this baby
right here I clearly could tell with the
blue eyes who that is this one yes
big beautiful blue eyes it's not
love I see Dan what oh you think this
one's Dan dude that would be mind
blowing everybody voted 85% for love
mind blowing that looks like a Swedish
uh
playroom and his father was into
photography so that would make sense for
the quality being
better looks like look like a Swedish
play I'm getting I'm getting
Ikea you can't
anything I see the toys I see the futon
I see the red blue and yellow that's
Ikea right blue and yellow those are the
Swedish colors so that's fair message
yeah yeah I cannot say anything I think
it's love I don't see Dan oh my God this
is really the hair is too light let me
see your hair my brain is starting to
hurt yeah the hair is too light it
that's not Dan oh my God I don't I don't
think so it be we could do a poll yeah I
mean know I mean go ahead I I'm not he
doesn't no so he's just speculating a
Dan all what's what am I asking is this
baby here Dan or love okay starting a PO
now the picture is kind of cryptically
aged so or Ian right that's not Ian Ian
has do have Blues he's got he's killing
me right I think the baby in the crib is
Cameron what no oh God ha dark eyes
you're way off man oh my God I think the
crib is sack
what are you guys with me no and
I think sack the picture we have for
sack is Cam Oh I thought this was going
to be people are going to have different
opinions so you know you got to just go
with your gut at the end of the day can
we see Zach
again dude this sack picture that ain't
no sack that's that's a cam no no no no
look at it again that's Zach I'm so sure
that's the only one I'm sure
of all right this so if we go to the
bottom wait wait yeah let's see that
that ain't no sack why no shot really
you think so black T-shirt and jeans
that's
Zach it's a rock and roll baby right
there I guess totally see I think it's
Zach man wait wait wait didn't Zach used
to say he used to pee in when his
cupboard or something is that the
cupboard used to pee in no he said it
was a chest it was a chest yeah I will
say there's a VCR on there Zach's pretty
young was he that old where DCR still
around old soul we weren't in the DVD
era how old are you I'm going to be 26
next month so I would say this kid's
like five about okay to break this there
I I watched uh vs okay okay so yeah I'm
younger all right fair enough fair
enough yeah be for sure I still feel
like that Zach so these ones are the the
two confusing ones I do believe this is
Dan this one's not fair it could be
anyone cuz it's like so early this one I
do believe is Love Actually now if
there's uh further consideration what do
the people which one did we say was
cam uh the closeup the like super
closeup one close the poll we did still
the majority of people 70% say this
bottom one here is love okay and I'm
inclined to believe to to agree so that
was what kicked off the whole
reshuffling was I think let's just lock
it in okay all right the only one I'm
really confused about is Ian which well
this is Ian so now I'm really confused
well so here's the chart so let's put's
put that last baby under your name
love and then the one on the bottom you
thought was love so are we saying that's
Ian let me take a
look no this is love the bottom one is
love yeah that's what I'm saying and the
one above it I guess it could be well
that one we said is
you that picture so I'm talking about
the one that you had previously to and
Ian this one is is it that one wait what
if what if the crib baby's Ian and one
that we think is Zach is Cameron with
the black
[Music]
hair what if this is the my baby back to
square one but this can't be in because
of the eye color mhm okay I see what
you're saying this be Olivia wait Olivia
you don't have blue eyes do
you
no God damn it let's just lock it in we
got to move on let's lock it in so
what's the final answer you're just
throwing that under Ian just put them
where what's not Ian why why don't we
swap Ian and Dan Ian and Dan cuz that
could be Dan right there's no shot dude
there's no
shot really that's my the one under AB
is confusing by the way that one's a
wild card that is kind of a wild card
yeah that one's a big wild card I I'm
not sure who this child is could that be
Ian yes it could so let's put this under
Ian
okay I think I see Ian's face now okay
so we're making the one in the high
chair yeah here you can see the screen
now right right right so that one Ian
and that one what a okay hold on think
so yeah hold on take that take Ian out
who else no that's Ian that's Ian right
that's the one you said was Ian who else
has got blue eyes right cuz that baby
has blue eyes
yeah
Dan
Sam and Ian no just Kidd be Sam it's
trolling Dan or Sam that's
it that one could be Sam that could be
Sam it could be Sam and Sam's a little
bit on the younger side right how old is
Sam uh 25 you
said yeah yeah yeah yeah so if we put
this baby under Sam what
happens then that baby that we put at
Sam could be comes a that doesn't seem
totally unreasonable to be honest yeah
AB yeah mhm right now you don't have AB
the eyes are so blue though I know they
can change but I don't know those eyes
look real blue the the the really young
baby with the towel I don't know
yeah it's hard to tell this that's kind
of like gray like how newborn that could
really be any color so let's do this AB
is a better guess than what we had yeah
yeah so let's review one final time okay
so put the one that's under Sam
currently under
ab and the one with the hat Under Sam
okay okay so Ela Ethan Dan Sam Ian
Cameron love Lena AB Olivia Zach here's
the ones I'll say I'm sure
about Zach Olivia
Lena
Love if any of those are wrong then I'm
really those yeah it's I think that's
fair those all seem fairly definitive
all right so let's reveal them one by by
one let's take a look all right I guess
from left to right and Ian do you just
want to give us like a a yes or no Ian
Ian's got the the master list so did we
get Ela right sure yes Ela is right did
we get Ethan right that is him that is
did we get Dan right no we did not no
did we get Sam right well hold on slow
down slow down well let's let's see how
loves marking off which ones are right
or wrong and then we can so let's let's
get them all and then we can figure out
one so did we get Sam right
no did we get Ian right no what do we
get Cameron right no what do we get love
right yes okay do we get Lena right yes
do we get AB right
no to be right did we get Olivia right
yes oh okay and did we get Zach right it
has to be
no dude I'm tell you what a TST what a
Twist I'm
seeing all right so what the so do
you so do you want the right answers do
you care can we fuss around with this
longer I feel like I don't know I mean I
could do it but I don't know if people
watch Z has to move to camera
now cam let's do it quickly Zach and cam
switch spots swap arino those two wait
yeah Zach and cam that's not Zach that
baby closeup oh there's no shot all
right just do the correct
order okay so starting from left to
right the incorrect ones so Dan I'm the
baby in the
Hat what yep that's me which one is
Sam a that makes no sense Sam Sam was
ab's yeah I think so there you go we had
that right you had that one right wait
hold on hold on hold on I can't believe
this is
Dan I told you dead half time AB tried
to give you a little bit of a hint my
dad D is a very good photographer and
that is an old photo but he always had
really nice cameras and that that is a
photo from 1987
wow holy smokes so that
admission about wi the Pooh was a red
herring it was a red herring but it was
true it was still what I said was true
and that that's why I knew it would
throw you off
sneaky all right moving
[Music]
on uh right so uh the one that was under
Ian was this one in the high chair that
was wrong where does that one belong Ian
that is AB that's AB which I think you
originally had we
that dang it I had to throw you a
curveball because all my other photos my
eyes are so big you would have
known right
away and then uh I guess so which one is
the real Ian where's the real Ian
sitting right now uh cam that's I knew
it is not fair is that one cam yes I
knew it oh my God the one you were so
confident that is a Jewish
baby I take it back and then love after
much debate you did get the love one
right that is love and then I think we
all know that we were right about Lena
yeah yeah yeah and then AB we know and
then Olivia that was the right
one yes yeah and then this is the
correct order and then Z at the end so
there you go the weenie the PO stuff was
that that was
Zach that look like a Jewish baby
Ethan that look like anymore I don't
anymore everything's in question
everything's question I don't know who I
am anymore that that looks like a baby
having an existential crisis after his
four skins been cut
off true I should have known the one
that really surprised me the most here
if you pull it up
again the Dan one really surprised so
I'm happy that you say that because um
we were I I dug around and found that
photo and and thought we should probably
use that one intentionally because all
the other photos that I could find of
me like you would just instantly know it
was me like here here was the other
alternative that I sent to Ian I'll pull
it up right
now uh where' it go I have a gallery of
the of the extra ones down send it at
the end okay if you want yeah if you can
shoot that over uh yeah I don't have
anything just the gallery I didn't send
you my extra one Ian but I just sent it
in
Discord I feel like you would have known
immediately this was me let me see
here's AB from another angle oh my God
that's the ever but you look so
different than that one that you sent my
God so
awesome oh that's great that's so
funny so cute yeah yeah yeah the little
suit kids eyes are so cute
yeah yeah but damn you really tricked me
on that last photo yeah definitely
tricked us okay what else we
got uh uh um Ian just sent the uh oh wow
that looks a lot like
album all right let's take a look here
this is definitely love right I mean
that looks just like you yeah that was
before he could find uh an actual baby
photo that he just found like a young
one is this the same playroom uh
no here is that's love that's also love
that's a sick ass baby right there I
only wore Flames as a baby that and I
also have the measurement tape on my hip
I saw
that nice this is who Sam that's Sam
that's Sam oh my God that
yeah what an outfit
W yo what is that that looks like Zach
that's big pimping blue right
there
sick that's
L dude I look the other way when that
baby catches my
eye I don't want that
SM this could be an album cover Zach you
know I've played with the idea of yeah
it's pretty
good whoa whoa that
hair oh my God who is that who is that I
don't know
Zach is that Z no that's not me Ian
right no that's that's me that's
me okay I can see a little bit I cannot
see it so hard to tell in some of these
that's me that's Dan yeah
God oh God and the Muppet Babies that
would have been a giveaway yeah that's
OB can use that
one oh okay that's like exactly Dan
that's what I'm saying we I found the
one photo of you that was kind of
ambiguous all the other just like you
holy look at the outfit thank you
thank you the we recreate this outfit wa
didn't my mom send a bunch more photos
in the VIP chat room Dan uh your dad
sent some n of them are baby photo well
this one's kind of a baby
photo you're pretty young here let's see
my parents didn't uh they didn't they
didn't care about uh the baby well it
was pretty short notice to be fair to
them this is Olivia for
sure let's see it oh there it is a cute
cute that one is very I feel like that's
too clearly me I couldn't use that one
yeah oh this next one where you're
smiling that that's just I've seen this
face on the show
God I that's her this is
her that's the wave before she before
she knew how to do it yo who's this cam
yo you look you look like a cool kid
dude W yo badass that's the only other
young photo I had but it looked like 10
or 11 there so older here's
a the kid
dope thanks man there's one picture that
love sent above
yeah I'm chenging sack there what the
one of you in the black underwear yeah
see love has had sass his whole life
look like look at oh my
god oh you got the squirt gun that so
funny gamer gamer moment you were saying
I was bald on the other picture it's
just I had like silver hair hair is yeah
it's like so blonde
it looks
translucent there it is yeah and you
brought up the fact that uh the photo
the baby photo me look like jet black
hair my hair was jet black as a kid too
so I went the opposite of love right so
it really does change in the middle this
is did loading for some reason but I'm
just going to send it to you oh see yeah
this is a good one I don't think it's
super obvious although my mom is in it
right you could have blurred her face I
don't know you think this is super
obvious yeah kind of
yeah looks I probably would have guessed
you first I see Theodore I do see both
my kids yeah love those guys so cool
dudes MH love my boys cool ass dudes
those kids they are the
best um well that was fun yeah yeah that
was
great we got a lot of other stuff to get
to but yeah we got to like nothing Let's
see we got Trump mugshot
we
got Logan Paul versus Dylan danis which
is I don't know whatever I guess there's
an interesting conversation to have
around like the way he's harassing his
fiance this guy Dylan
danis um logal Paul hasn't paid anyone
back coffeezilla is making a website
about him like we
did Love
That Let's see loganpaul scams.com yo
that's a sick domain Logan Paul
scams.com that's
good that's really good the problem is
love pointed this
out his SEO is going to be way more
difficult to break through on than
uh this website looks like it needs some
work too yeah there's uh the issue with
this SEO wise there's not enough text
not enough text cuz all the images
include the text the text should be on
the website you're not going to
that makes sense get caught up in search
this is a fantast it's been 224 days
since Logan ball the live counter we had
a live counter too this is a fantastic
idea though cuz Logan is really just
such a piece of scammer I mean what
the I am personally committing a
th000 e to this which is about $1.3
million uh here he is getting sound like
that Harvey wiste clip that we have on
our
website sure yeah here is uh Dylan
dannis I guess he's uh gearing up to
fight this guy okay one you friends with
Conor McGregor where is he by the way
where's coach McGregor and why won't he
take my bet be here heack why take my
million doll bet why won't you pay back
to people from crypto Zoo I'm working on
it D he actually such a good disc
because Logan's like I have a million
dollars to bet with but I don't have a
million dollars to pay back the scumbag
yeah what are you working on this is the
cease and toist from Logan's uh lawyer
we represent Logan Paul Mr Paul has
informed us of your Outreach about the
status of the crypto zo egg buyback Mr
Paul remains committed to this process
it's been almost a
year God dumbass crypto
intelligence news reported that Logan
Paul is upset he didn't get enough
credit for his announcement and changed
his
mind no shot that's true well I mean it
is true so
far source with ties to Paul and then
now defun project has now told crypto
intelligence news what the hell is
that that the American influencer has
changed his mind about compensating
investors specifically The Source said
that Paul was unhappy with the response
he received online after he announced
his intentions to compensate investors
from his own pocket feeling that he
didn't receive enough
credit I could see him saying that so
he's not going to do it cuz he's not
going to get enough pra you know if
you're going to be thought of the de to
as the devil you might as well be the
devil but you you need to do the right
thing doesn't matter about the right
thing but Logan Paul that's that's
secondary like you're doing the right
thing is not going to get you praise
you're just doing the right thing well
also you already pledged It
Dummy um hear from the victim yeah and
then he's saying it and then taking it
back wow look at this so this is a cool
thing that we should keep following I
think but uh that's a great idea by
coffeezilla appreciate
that apparently he got blocked someone
got blocked for posting
this I mean that would be a really
valuable engagement
egg um so there's that there's oh this
Jordan Peterson update is pretty good
let's go so he was there's also firefest
2.0 he's back and he's making firefest
2.0 the same guy no yeah Billy what's
his name yeah Billy McFarland yeah he
made a video and everything what
pretty good it's pretty
insane would anyone be dumb enough to
buy a ticket well we were thinking about
buying I can understand that but I was
said listen there's no shot this happens
there's zero% shot this happen so we're
just going to give him money for nothing
is anyone buying tickets well no they're
not and you can tell okay cuz when we
looked at this he has these
tiar 100 tickets weren't even sold when
we were looking at
this so he suckered at least a 100
people into buying a $500 ticket on this
website look how it
is can't imagine who would still go and
buy this well it's less than 100 so the
rest is just coming soon and that one
sold out and look at the prices dude
uh listen if you get tickets now guys
you can get it for 800 but if you
wait for the last chance pre-sale it's
going to cost you
8,000 so the 777 tickets did you notice
that what does that mean there's only
777 tickets oh no that's just the
pre-sale ones oh okay these are the good
the deals these are the sick
deals and by the way uh
remember they have good new trous
gourmet meals for everybody oh my God
that's you know that's a good ass meal
right there why up happening to him did
he go to jail I think
so he did yeah and is he out yeah he's
out and now he's out and he's
immediately doing doing another one I
thought there was a court order that he
couldn't start another business again
that's what I'm confused about oh well
he doesn't seem to be one can you fact
check that maybe he's out of country
right maybe he's in the Caribbean
no are you mixing him up with Martin scy
no it's pretty
[Applause]
sure thanks bro thanks fire Festival
yeah well now that we're on this let's
just get into it it's very good uh he
made a
video he's out of prison for fraud and
he's turned out a 50-page business plan
for fire Festival the
Revival he back it's back where it
started YouTube video posted Sunday here
it is the big
announcement on
Instagram there he is man I haven't seen
his face in a while I missed you
buddy and obviously his reach is uh
fantastic he has 1,200
likes so those tickets are going to sell
themselves what a loser this guy's a
straight up scam loser man and I'm so
glad to see like nobody cares about him
look at
this sometimes these scammers get like a
cult following marelli for example he
doesn't have
he's have like a 100 likes 600
likes 500 likes nobody cares man we love
that so here it
is as you can see put a lot of effort
into this guys this is a big day because
as of right now fire Fest he's giving me
Donald Trump Jr two tickets are
officially on sale it has been the
absolute wildest journey to get here and
it really all started during the seventh
month yeah man it was really wild I did
a fraud I went to jail I was banned from
opening a new business so I moved to
Caribbean and now I'm ready to do it all
again baby stint in solitary confinement
i' wrote out this 50-page plan if how it
would take this overall interest and
demand in fire and how it would take my
ability to bring people from around the
world together to make the impossible
happen but how would find the best
Partners in the world to allow me to be
me while executing Fire's Vision to the
highest level in my first year I
partnered one of the biggest and I don't
does I don't know what he's thinking
with this I don't know either like who
does he think he's talking to the way
he's speaking like he's doing a TED talk
or something also the robe and he's
trying to he's trying to show that he's
Rich it's like boy you don't came out of
jail yeah you're
pennil you better be
pennil what a weirdo best TV companies
in the world to produce a documentary
called after the fire I've also worked
one of the biggest production companies
to sign a deal to produce fire Festival
the Broadway musical and you are not
making yes see that's funny but the way
he's presenting it is not
funny the only people I can see going is
like content creators just to get
content out of it like we were saying we
were asking Ethan if we could buy
tickets he said no he said no well I
said I said I'm down but oh did you I
said listen I'm down but if we buy him
right now we he's just going to steal
our money yeah know I think that's a
good point he he we're just donating
$500 to it might not even happen I it's
not happening it's 0% not
happening
finally today we are announcing fire
Festival 2o we spoke to people as far
away as the Middle East and South
America and ultimately we decided that
fire Festival 2 is coming back to the
Caribbean finally we're targeting fire
Festival 2 for the end of next year and
in the mean time we'll be doing popups
and events across the world yes guys
this is your chance to get in this is
everything I've been working towards
let's F and go let's F go dude go yes
he's back he's is trying so hard to
sound like charismatic or something I
don't know what is this delivery that
he's doing they talked about him in the
documentary like this incredible
persuasive businessman this man has no
Riz no but it's possible that this is
after like everything that's happened he
got maybe the sheen is gone the shine is
gone the guild is
gone just looks like a piece of
where is he this looks like maybe
New York or La so he's I think it's New
York he's in the he's in the United
States yeah there was another video of
him when he was on the street uh looked
like New York so the terms and agreement
do stipulate that McFarland remain under
supervision released for 3 years placing
him under the jurisdiction of the US
probation office he's required to check
in with probation officers regularly
also under the deal McFarland is
required to work at least 30 hours per
week at a lawful type of employment
unless the probation officer excuses you
from doing so huh so can he make his own
business and then yeah there's nowhere
yeah there's nowhere in the conditions I
say he can't um that's from
NPR well that seems like a oversight
well he's back the comments are pretty
good cool can't wait to not go no venue
no lineup just a destination and a
promise I'm sure it's going to be
amazing here take my
money I want the confidence to announce
an on sale an on sale in a Rob
yeah there it is so everyone's lining up
very exciting I want more information
about this musical I have more
information
um here's a Tik Tok announcement about
the musical it's very cool very cool
another super high production value uh
what's up good morning guys have some
huge news today yeah yeah dude
thank
you okay
I got that hot and spicy dude yes sir oh
the toppings are on the side
interesting okay let me hit this
mhm I was waiting for
it
no my new favorite sound man it's so
funny
pet you got to hit those
fries
I am hitting
them so let's
watch they did a post a few weeks ago
teasing fire Festival 2 I'm sure you saw
it it went totally crazy So the plan was
to do fire Festival 1.5 as a Broadway
musical wait did he say that post went
totally
crazy uh this I believe what what's the
date on this this is actually older than
this is from May right so yeah he's been
talking about bringing fire Festival
back for a few months now totally
crazy yeah that must have been the
initial tease that he
gave totally blew up what's up good
morning guys have some huge news today I
did a post a few weeks ago teasing fire
Festival 2o I'm sure you saw it it went
totally crazy the plan was to do fire
Festival 1.5 as a but things totally
blew up so I'm announcing two things
today one that fire Festival 1.5 is
going to be a Broadway musical and that
two we were in talks with partners to
pay back all of my restitution and
execute fire Festival 2 according to the
original Vision on this incredible and
beautiful island we have to do it right
guys and have to make happen what to
drink how was this dude requirement how
are you for
real you don't have to do fire Festival
2 you kind of have to not do it yeah
that seems like the wiser R we're super
excited to announce that I've partnered
up with Lyn Manuel to be doing the
score he said at some point I guess it
wasn't in that but Olivia didn't we hear
that um that he didn't want to hire
traditional Broadway people but it was
all going to be pop stars like he this
this this musical's different it's G to
be um starring only a-listers and it's
like this man
stry dude I've got a crazy idea I'm
going to make a Broadway musical but
only get aist celebrities dude
wow y That's so smart that's
genius like that is a great idea that
would pull a lot of a lot of ticket
sales you're right it would be very
successful if you were able to do that
which you are
not
well I'm reading right now that he still
owes roughly 60 or 26 million in
restitution for holy oh my God fire
Festival so okay
well you doing ticket isn't the ticket
money just going straight to that like
what I thought he had a forfeit 26
million but let me let me double he does
have in no way well Ariana Grande's
gonna star in it and she's gonna him all
his money
back McFarland's lawyer he by the way
he's the only one actually getting paid
McFarland's lawyer Jason Russo has
previously said that his client is
committed to repaying the roughly 26
million he owes for his crimes good man
I'm happy to hear you're committed to
it mhm the same way Logan's committed
I'm committed to gracefully losing to J
shett just all I can say is thank God
he's not using um I forgot his first
name but the last name singer as his
attorney because everyone use that guy
Ryan Singer what's his
name I was just reading something in the
document that mentioned him again
representing someone it's lizo maybe
lizo yeah it's lizo listen to this Marty
singer he keeps coming Up Wait who's
Marty Sanger it's Marty Sanger who's
that he's a lawyer that represents the
biggest scumbags in the world they all
flocked to him what's his clientele
again there was the long list of it's
like every like cancelled celebrity over
the last 20 years but it should be
pointed out I saw other people point out
um his Client List is a lot more
expansive than that and it's a lot of
people that aren't controversial he's
just he's a really good lawyer so of
course like you know big celebrities
that are of trouble go to
him I don't know you look guilty when
you H this guy in my
opinion uh yeah it's about lizo though
actually lizo we follow we follow
destroy she was sued by former dancers
yeah so lizzo's lawyer Marty singer it's
just odd I've mention I've talked about
this guy like three times yeah I mean
big lawyer like he represented uh was it
Kevin
Spacey yeah it was like it was the the
70 show guy who was Harding people
yeah Brian Singer the grossest dude
alive
M read the list it's unel I'm pulling it
up right now let's unable uh Charlie
Sheen John Travolta Brett
Ratner uh see this is this is this list
is like everything so also like Zoe Zoe
Des Shanel Ricky Martin Kim Kardashian
Tristan
Thomas
uh right I'm looking for like the
cancelled list uh Bill
Cosby Chris
Brown how good can he be D I mean
probably pretty good let's be
real like Bill Cosby from jail not that
good no he's not jail he's not jail he's
out of jail he is out of jail yeah on
technicality holy on a technicality
which sounds like something that are
really good lawyer would be able to pull
off actually you're right you know
someday I'm gonna have to hire him would
that be the ultimate irony let's hope
not I'll be like yo hopefully we don't
need him we got to go with b or Marty
he'll be like I remember you you
piece of
I need you
Marty nobody can get me out of
this
um lizza's lawyer Marty singer shared
photos with people of the former dancers
allegedly happily cavorting backstage
with performers from crazy hes topless
cabaret
show after they claimed lizo pressured
them into attending the performance
while on tour in the lawsuit that
doesn't seem like really convincing
evidence does it that is such a stupid
point
yeah um we have a picture of everybody
smiling so it wasn't it's just one
picture these images a picture or a
video it's a picture yeah I mean what
are you going to pull from that's dumb
yeah here's
describes these images showing the three
plaintiffs gleefully reving backstage
after the toplist show were taken after
their February 2023
visit uh singer wrote in a statement
referencing another club where they
claimed to have been pressured that's
insanely dumb mhm see they're smiling I
have a picture of them smiling from that
day that doesn't seem like good
lawyering I mean it may be dumb but it
only needs to be convincing to uh the
jury
right if that's the best they've got
it's not good
sure
um sorry guys I'm
hungry in the plaintiff's lawsuit their
legal team claimed that lizo invited the
dancers to attend the
show but failed to mention their
performing
nude at a
cabaret
is Cabaret always nude I think so I
don't know enough Cabaret are I think
they're I don't think that's not Cabaret
are what I thought racy but not
necessarily fully nude but why are they
acting like such prudes I mean what the
what's a
little seems a little
silly there's a lot of I feel there's a
lot of reasons someone wouldn't want to
go on that let's see Cabaret religious
maybe uh not the music dance for lizo
they're in Hollywood they're
I mean okay I don't maybe you're
uncomfortable wasn't it wasn't the
cabaret show in France or somewhere in
Europe Netherlands it was like some
prestigious like Cabaret thing that from
it wasn't some seedy uh strip
joint like professional dancers but
didn't they they did go to a strip joint
separate well that's a separate story
The separate one and that was the one
where things were getting shot at of
coochies and stuff and I'm just I'm
describing what they included this
anecdote right I got you she took us to
a prestigious Cabaret in the Netherlands
and their tits were
out and we're suing you come on that's
silly am I wrong that seems
silly I think you're wrong they're
adults I mean what the you're
taking an isolation it the the
accusations are that's
one I'm talking about this one yeah but
the case is like the whole thing
so right but that one seems I'm sorry it
just seems silly like dude no I feel you
what are you TW I mean what the I'm
sorry just
leave that well that was the whole thing
felt pressured to leave or to to
attend I feel that including that
anecdote makes the the other accusations
look less credible in my
opinion because it's so stupid I'm sorry
somebody has to say it it's just so dumb
you know what I mean it is the other
is is crazier right but it just
makes it look like potentially a bad
faith
lawsuit I don't know what happened but
would you do like go to a with a work
trip to a place where dude she's a
she's they're a professional
dancers they're a rock star they tour
they do all kinds of crazy you know
I mean I'm sure crazy goes down on
the tour you know you know and then
you're in Netherlands in Europe
toplessness is like fairly reg fairly
normalized it's not even really super
sexual there like it is in America yeah
so like if you walk into a
reputable place that's like known for
being really professional Cabaret and
you see some
titties I'm sorry but that's not I don't
think it's reasonable to assume that
that is going to induce some kind of
trauma it just like come on who are we
kidding is this the same place where she
was supposedly making them eat bananas
out of the dancers no that was what I
was trying to say there there was
separate like strip club strip club part
that that stuff was crazy yeah that that
but that's what I'm saying Ethan is like
the lawsuit isn't just about this if it
if it was just about this I would
probably agree with you but when it's it
seems like the lawsuit they're including
that because it's part of a pattern yeah
of making not this isolated thing on its
own right
it's portraying like a bigger picture
it's
exactly I understand that if it was just
the Cabaret thing I think I would 100%
agree with you I understand that I feel
it's it's just silly to include it I
don't know it's just silly like we're
going to come on man fair enough you're
going to act like you're traumatized
because you saw a professional Cabaret
in their boobs R these are grown ass
women grown women they're not acting
like that they're just establishing a
pattern they're not saying that this is
traumatizing they're saying that yo look
she did this she did this she did this
she's done this for all her employees I
feel
like in Paris the dancers alleged lizo
invited them to a club so they would be
able to learn something or be inspired
by
them professional dancers at a reputable
Cabaret and then no it turned out to be
a nude
Cabaret their boobs were out their boobs
that she would make the Assumption I
guess
that everybody would if we were all
going I'm not Lio we're not professional
dancers it doesn't matter go ahead
finish your finish your we're going to
see another podcast I don't know and
they're all going to be performing nude
it would be a conversation before we go
like hey is everybody okay with this are
you guys sure that would yeah that would
be proper to do so it's it's it's
describing the full you know the full
picture
that that's all I don't think they're
saying they're traumatized for
me okay not going to argue with you guys
about it I mean you wouldn't have done
that of course I wouldn't have done
it this is a silly Hill to die on I
guess I'm sorry they're they're just
it's baby they're being
babies the chat earlier was pretty
divided there was quite a few people
were saying they agree with you so I
don't know I think you have a point but
only when talking about the incident in
I that's all I'm doing I think it's fair
to include it as part of a I don't think
they like in the lawsuit they named a
few it wasn't like a laundry list I
think it was like the Cabaret and the
strip club and that was it and then
there was other stuff like fat shaving
and harassing which is bad obviously mhm
but like if you're trying to show a
history of sexual
harassment and the two one of the
examples is this it's it's not very
convincing the other example is horrible
right I would think I wouldn't even
include this the other one is bad
enough that's okay but I mean that's
just like a a lawyer's decision I guess
how they want to write their
argument Marty Marty singer oh wait he
right he doesn't represent the people
suing he's he's team Ethan Marty singer
in the plaintiff's lawsuit their legal
team claimed lizo invited yada yada she
invited them to learn it was a nude
Cabaret Davis William and Rodriguez
attorney claims in a statement of two
people they stand by every claim y
yada yeah they basically said there's
really there's really the only update is
the stupid photo that she tried to
release isn't the update that she's um
conter suing them yeah she's counter
suing them them for what and they they
were like these the her attorney was
like look at these photos the shows they
were having a good time and then the
attorneys for the plaintiffs are saying
that uh this doesn't prove anything this
is just they were afraid to lose their
jobs which is what we were alleging from
the
beginning I don't know I feel like in in
general we we infant we're infan tiling
people too much
like to a certain degree it's like you
know maybe you're a little
uncomfy it's a
adult professional dance
place I mean we're treating them like
babies they're acting like babies in
that case the focus is the aor stuff
that are more problematic not that was
included as one of the main things
whatever I have um if you want open I
send it in Instagram uh a
link and I think if if the if we need
anything to prove that Lisa is guilty
you guys should watch that video which
one do you have it in it's in WhatsApp
what is
it well I'm waiting to know if you you
guys have it did you just send it no
earlier
today it's this uh Alex Mayo
one which one is it this one oh yeah
Alex Mayo one this all right pull it up
here I have it on the screen so what do
we what do we think about scroll over to
the video oh wait hold
on which one is it there we go scroll
over to the
video so this was outside the Met Gala
do you guys recognize somebody at the
front that's our our girl Taylor she was
there doing makeup for
um God why am I forgetting his name now
I'm blanking out but she was there
working doing makeup and Lio and her bu
girl just came and pushed her over wait
what crazy video and and like Taylor
wasn't like a fan there she was one of
the people working there you know it
looks like he's trying to get out of
there and it's all crazy yo what the
I think we need to
for that emotional distress you know
what I
mean don't B my girl around like that
he's not even facing her straight
traumatized dude yep her bodyguard
bumped shoulders with me and I literally
can't sleep anymore mhm I have
nightmares
yes but she's threatening to counter Su
I guess so that's the lizo stuffff I
don't
know threatening to counos so is kind of
um it doesn't really mean much not but I
mean that would not be a good move on
her part I feel like it depends on the
evidence if their evidence is this one
picture of them smiling that's really
dumb really dumb you
know
okay if lizo was a male singer he'd
never be able to hire a female dancer
again I I disagree on we just talking
about the one Cabaret thing but talk
about the other stuff not the CET well I
agree the other stuff is bad there's
only two things well why you can't
separate saying that Ethan you are being
too hurt you're being very hurtful
listen am
I come
on Ean being a little rude stop looking
at the chat turn
off it's like going to yeah but it's
forced kind of we're just the
conversation is going in circles now
said your peace let's how is it forced
virtually forced cuz they were they
think that it might negatively impact
their their job if they don't
go AKA in my opinion it's kind of for so
so if she took them to a Broadway show
and there was and and these are adults
they go to a Broadway show and then one
of the actresses has a nude scene are we
going to say it's traumatic and that I
felt forced to be there cuz that's
essentially the same thing it's a
professional production a reputable
production I don't know I mean I'm not
the Arbiter where the line is somewhere
there line I think I think it should be
I mean yeah I don't know listen if
people are if you guys are getting
offended that's not I'm just trying to
have a conversation if if this offends
you then I apologize uh but it shouldn't
really in my opinion I'm just discussing
something you know what I mean but okay
there it is shout out for those of you
guys who found the Vlog to be offensive
I'm sorry you did for those of you who
didn't find it to be offensive I'm sorry
they did thank
you guys we need to be able to have
tough conversations taboo topics these
are taboo topics exactly AB been and
preach wish they could have high level
taboo
topic all right so that's lizo what
happened should have happened what
should have happened happened and it is
what it
is
um let's
see so we've got oh yeah the Jordan
Peter scene thing I wanted to talk about
so there was this big case that he was
talking about
yeah the board of psychologists of
Ontario had accused
Jordan of being
unethical specifically they said he
engaged in degrading demeaning and
unprofessional comments which is against
their code of conduct as as you know as
a board as a organization of
psychologists yeah I guess uh because I
was confused by this at first we should
clarify that even though it's called the
College of psychologist or whatever that
that's just it's the bar EXA exactly for
for lawyers it's like the bar it's like
a a professional regulatory you can't
practice without
their license yeah same as the bar
professional accreditation and lawyers
can get disbarred for doing dumb
too right happens Rudy Giuliani for
example right he's
disbarred
so last November the college as I said
said uh demeaning and all this stuff and
it's related to his appearance on the
Joe Rogan podcast where he identified
himself as a clinical psychologist and
appeared to demean a former client that
was specifically wow the college ethic
code requires members to use respectful
language and not engage in unjust
discrimination the complaints committee
concluded that some of Peterson's
comments posted a moderate risk of harm
to the public including undermining
public trust in the profession of
psychology as well as Peterson's uh
language uh an unwillingness to
acknowledge the complaints committee's
concern so he has used
this as like a crusade since it happened
against free speech I guess it's really
just like the bar they're like yo you're
you're talking on former clients
using really hurtful language there
there is a Baseline code of conduct
for got to be professional right it's
the same thing with lawyers the same
thing with doctors like you have lawyer
client um you know what's the term
confidentiality confidentiality I mean
how gross is that to on a
former
client I
doubt I remember I don't remember the
specifics of what he said but I remember
that part of that Joe Rogan episode and
he he took it at the time too cuz that
is kind of crazy for psychologist did he
say their name though no no yeah do we
have that part we going to watch it um I
find yeah I recall him doing something
like that when we were talking to him
too he would he does that a lot my
former client really although I don't
think he degraded
them also like imagine what it says
about him he he has open disdain for the
person he's there to
help yeah that's not okay right and I
think that's why they have a good point
with like undermining the Trust In
psychologists because if you see him as
an example of like an accredited
psychologist and it's like oh I'm going
to go tell all my personal confessional
stuff to this guy and he's going to go
blasted on a podcast they're going to be
sitting there judging me right instead
of you know listening that's terrible
right so he's been going on Joe Rogan
online and he's crying about free he
crying his tweets about this have been
so unhinged let me see uh they so they
ordered
him uh to pay2 $5,000
fine for basically for wasting their
time well and then well then they said
that there's still a review that's going
to move forward he was trying to get rid
of the review so I think they're
reviewing the the whole situation to see
if they need to uh disbar him or not uh
well
it's it's actually even stupider than
that I mean yes that that can ultimately
happen to him but what this is all over
is they want him to take a social media
sensitivity training court that part is
so stupid and that's that's what all of
this is him fighting having to go to a
thing where they're like hey maybe don't
you know deadname Elliot pagee on
Twitter anymore I feel like it doesn't
even need to be related to social media
like right but that was the that was
like their biggest like kind of his his
public statements and everything like
when you get a ticket they make you do
the driver's ed it's like driver's ed
yeah
that's an infringement of my rights it
just makes it feel stupid it is dumb the
whole thing and that's the point even in
the beginning with the whole trans thing
forced that was also dumb he's not being
honest about the the stuff he's just
he's just using the outrage to to propel
himself MH and uh it's really not that
serious so says so the Ontario Court of
appe of appeal ruled that CP Ontario can
pursue their prosecution if you think
think you have the right to free speech
in Canada you're delusional now remember
they're not saying I'm going to arrest
you they're saying you're a bad
psychologist yeah and so we're thinking
that you shouldn't be able to practice
anymore right which by the way he hasn't
since 2017 or something so so so it's
like it's over a license that he doesn't
even use this free speech thing is
literally irrelevant it's irrelevant
yeah it's you being professional with
your client and you know this this is
what they do on the right they turn
everything into this absurd free speech
thing it's really so pathetic yeah so if
you think you have right to free speech
a canidate you're delusional I will make
every aspect of this public and we will
see what happens when utter transparency
is the rule bring it on bro you already
lost what are you talking about bring it
on you you
lost it's over you owe him 25k bro uh
and keeping with the transparency here's
the decision the courts are captured by
the woke ideologies I knew this already
but I did not fully understand the
extent sure you didn't this is just that
it's the whole thing yeah he knows
nobody's going to read this by the way
right nobody fact he probably didn't
even read it to be honest with
you so oh let me see that reply oh yeah
there's some good replies for example
Elon Musk with one of his iconic uh
responses you're going to love this one
I'm sure it'll be thoughtful and
insightful as always here it is Elon mus
had this to
say
wow
wow I would he could have dropped a this
is uh
concerning I think he's become
self-conscious about the concerning
thing cuz he was getting me not so hard
the concerning it seems like the
concerning uh been retired for now like
bro you can just like it you don't have
to reply with wow he's trying to signal
boost it yeah
just Elon Musk is and he was
writing that Vivic Viv ra raas Swami
Vivic thec VI thec I like that no v v v
like cake just think like cake uhhuh
okay you blew it
VI he was tweeting about he he's looking
good and this guy is ful
anti-abortion he wants to demolish the
Department of
Education he wants to IRS El is probably
also anti abortion he's got like a
million kids yeah he thinks that uh
maybe that's what he stands for
interesting he does actually talk pretty
frequently about population Decline and
what a big problem that well that's
really not a great way to fix the
problem up families yeah yeah but
okay yeah the pan yada yada
yada he posted a brief video response
let's
go let's go he's in his a Batman super
villain outfit oh my god dude can you
stop what are you what's wrong with you
posted this directly to Twitter what the
F this is not fashion no this is mental
uh hello everyone this is mental you
know I don't like to say mental but in
his case I will this is mental illness
yeah the orange doesn't even the shades
don't even go together that tie and the
jacket so I think uh somebody pointed
out that it it's some uh it's based off
of his icon right like if you look at
his Twitter icon he has that like kind
of abstract painting or something and
this is I guess oh he's having custom I
guess made for him isn't it it's
embroidered with his name on the Lael as
well I think that's does kind of look
like something that's been made custom
that's definitely custom there's no
question people don't sell that garbage
hello every so he went out he went out
of his way to wear
this so let's see what Twoface has to
say about the about
one uh I've been awaiting a Court
decision in Canada I've been awaiting
with regards to the Ontario College of
psychologist decision to he is so
self-important since he joined the uh
daily wire the daily wire look at this
man he he he truly
believes there you go how important he
is you can feel it he he yeah he's so
important this is um I see to show this
is the thing that it is I guess based on
yeah the the the panel on
Ontario they they did a grave blow to me
and the men everywhere hello everyone
hello
uh I've been awaiting a Court decision
in Canada he's reading with regards to
the Ontario College of psychologist
decision to require me to be re-educated
in relationship to my social media use
or to lose my license the Court ruled
today in favor of the college uh they
claimed that I have the right to free
speech in Canada but subject to
apparently whatever limitations the
college wants dude you're on a
profession
organization you like he understands
that of course he does like he's just a
piece of yeah it's not free
speech I have a lawyer I have a lawyer
friend I'll tell you what he stole their
he stole their settlement
money and he got disbarred now what kind
of crap is
that I don't have freedom freedom to
steal my client's money
I was
disbarred to place on me and by
implication every other professional in
Canada and by implication every other
citizen of Canada that's some big
implications you're doing there buddy
and therefore everybody in the world all
the known universe it affects all of us
man but subject to apparently whatever
limitations the college wants to place
on me and by implication every other
professional in Canada and by
implication every other citizen of
Canada every citizen of the whole world
there was that whole chain of
implications no well I see what you did
there
Jordy my very exclusive Board of
psychologist where do you think his
notes are he keeps looking down why does
he need notes for this anyway yeah I
mean Xanax does affect memory
M response to that my full response to
that or my full initial response to be
more accurate um we'll release that
tomorrow so stay tuned and I hope you
find it useful and and interesting hello
everyone wow wow what
a MH 20,000 likes so wait is that out cu
I'd love to watch I guess it might be
cuz yeah I grabbed that last night
stream awards are trending what's
happening I see here they added more
people AA enemy of the
show of
the um Michelle friend of the show
friend of the show okay see we got
friends we got friends and Matt Pat I
like Matt Pat okay some people in the
chat are saying I'm sorry I love the
jacket you
guys the Peterson jacket yeah give me a
break people come on what what's
happening that's literally just looks
like someone dropped a paint bugget on
him the orange of the tie doesn't even
go with the jacket that's just
unforgivable so did he drop that
video can anyone take a look for it oh
God I'm looking okay he said it was it
should be up by now here's um an album
of unhinged Jordan tweets about it as
you can there's got to be just about it
the thing is is that
um the um the skitso posting on Jordan's
account panderer this man he presents
himself to be so enlightened and he's on
the he's on this prestigious board the
thing is if you follow him on Twitter
and are able you get a peek into his
mind he is utterly addicted to Twitter
and like the shallowest most pathetic
way he has no restraint he he his his
emotional moods are stunning this is a
unhinged man who has no self-control by
the way cuz he he humiliates himself
every day look at this you bloody
panders CB CBC News meta told him this
was going to happen then he instituted
his careless arrogant law then it
happened and new pathetic minions
moralized in his favor he posted a
picture of a
Minion I mean this alone should take you
off the board he he Minion posts quite a
bit as a matter of he really likes the
minions so what was he in response to
prime minister Justin tro has blasted
social media giant meta over its
decision to block local news as
wildfires continue to force so wait
what's his problem with
that meta told him this was going to
happen then he institut his Carol like
arrogant law and then it happened
literally what that's probably some
Canadian he hates by the way hat yeah
can you imagine if your therapist is
posting minion memes that's on Twitter
well it's like in curb when he saw his
therapist in the thong at the beach it's
worse than that
this is frankly yeah let's keep going
cuz it gets a lot worse that one was
like somewhat coherent keep telling
Justin Trudeau and his DED
minions and this person of the CCP to go
to hell so we have a minion with Know
Your Meme yep and then this what the
I don't know what the that is
a it's a drawing he very much likes as
you'll see it reminds me of like the
kind of drawing that like the teacher
shows
the parents of like a
dist they're worried going to be a
school happening at home right listen to
authorities uh I don't know who he keeps
tagging but here's the minion it's
really not that good of a point not
funny and
weird screenshot the fact that like the
phone screenshot is so funny the whole
phone what the f nothing that's so wild
to me
um look how he writes this so this is
where like most of his tweets are like
this now he like writes in this strange
like kind of poetic uh yeah so poetic
way like he's trying to like write huz
or something I I don't it looks to me as
if he's just
like under some kind of influence
well the remnants of the child of a
devouring mother oh what so here's Ursa
or Ursula is so funny from The Little
Mermaid uhuh and then some girl on a
backpack with a f yeah on a that's it's
a backpack yeah wait he didn't he pull
it a backpack it's a backpack you didn't
find a damn uhhuh no this is
psycho this this man is meant to be
respected by the world over not a
picture of a
backpack of twet I would like I want to
see how how he finds the pictures can we
like try to backrack what Google search
like bad guy from Little
Mermaid how do you get that back Peto so
conf this was in response to the tragic
life of jazz Jenning is an in uh
indictment of the trans Lobby having
transitioned at a young age the reality
TV star now suffers from countless
mental health and psychological problems
this is a cautionary tale says Malcolm
Clark so they're saying they
transitioned at a young age and now
they're being paraded around
conservative
media so he he he thinks the parents of
trans kids are
psychopaths and I guess her mom her mom
is like Ursa she turned her daughter
into the Joker and then her mom the
analogies are with Little Mermaid Jer
chur and this guy's apparently a
literary
Master this is a poem this is utterly
non this is
nonsense okay going on hey
Mick it was fun talking to you today in
La for the relaunch of your podcast
that's his daughter yeah so talking to
his daughter on
Twitter referring to hey Mick and then
this is just like such a weird
like was she not ready for that photo
it's like this is like a creeper shot
yeah hey hey Mick
it was great also it's like an old
friend is your daughter great catching
up hey Mick nice to cross pass with you
today hit me up next time you're in La
we can get coffee
together um look out here I
come uh I don't even know cuz it was
erased but it's a picture of him and
drag and an emblem of a squid is that a
Marvel thing is that like the Hydra
thing or something I don't dude I got no
idea I'm not sure what we're
going for with this one I must say that
I've had some postcoidal regrets about
that
phrase what here is a just a swinky face
apparently comparing himself to oh I
know who this is this is the uh this is
from from maroin 3 or whatever oh
yeah gorath he's
the he doesn't know who that is wow I
did not realize that at all a video game
and he's the god of like uh Mischief
Insanity
insanity and so that's so funny what is
happening right now I didn't even catch
thinks that that's him the God of
Insanity okay go off cuz the half and
half
suits okay okay right very good yes it's
me
the God of Insanity this picture
again Trump charged with questioning
election results while not being a
Democrat and this is his
response amazing explain this
somebody hi Mrs Peterson I have some
concerns about your son Jordan do you
have time to talk for a
moment he's been doing some really
disturbing
images um I I just want to make sure
you're aware of it and I just need to
check that everything's okay at home is
that okay up yours okay we're going to
be doing a wellness check there's going
to be social workers coming over to your
house just to make sure everything looks
okay L MF
o sheer bloody
evil this one again the narcissism of
compassion the devouring mother the whr
of Babylon Unforgivable
J God I'm assuming he's talking
about uh the mother of a trans person
he's obsessed with this idea of like the
devouring mother yeah the chaos
Dragon but Joker female Joker is that
the best representation of the devouring
mother there's nothing maternal about
Joker yeah uh it's just a bad analogy
and image is weird it's very strange so
he has a meme folder uh-huh yeah he
reuses a lot of these yeah this next one
is one that he uses a lot too and I I
got to tell you this is this is by far
the strangest one not you anyone but you
take my license take it now Gad sad I
don't know anything about Gad sad but
he's like a rightwing bag right I I
don't know I kind of recognize the name
but I I don't I he's been on Rogan does
this picture have to do with it I don't
know he posts that a lot he tweets it
literally every day he tweets that bird
like look at this there's no context
even on this
one there C just I mean he's seeing
faces he's like the TV is talking to him
you know what I mean like the images are
talking to him and giving meaning but
nobody knows what the he's talking
about he just uses it as like yeah as
just like a meme response what is what
is this bird posted in response to
what's the quote tweet uh rock stars
used to throw TVs out of hotel rooms and
eat the head off bats now they State
biological facts and issue apology
statements in
response the
bird and what is I don't think this is
an endanger bird or anything I think
I've seen this in the zoo it's just it's
a really cool bird a beautiful
bird and so it's a shoe bu St a shoe
build St Sho build star how did you know
that I know my birds kid bird guy I was
Googling it okay yeah um let's go to his
Twitter account actually I love this
let's see this is
pinned man got a grip with regards to
the
Ontario well at least you didn't hire
Canadians hash then he keeps tagging
Elon like please notice me it's pathetic
so
pathetic he did post a 40 minute
response by the way on his YouTube oh
send it
all send that
send me that good
brother
um impossible to parody here's what you
need to know about the new Co vaccine
and why you should get it his response
it's impossible to
parody what seems like a pretty
straightforward yeah he's become
brutally antiva yeah which is an anti an
logic and he's he's Pro cercy he's Pro
Madness Pro
Madness that's his uh that's his uh
platform prison for life in response to
nearly a decade after pursuing a
disastrous medical transition Pria
Mosley has sued the doctor and therapist
who encouraged her to make life-altering
changes prison for life for the the
doctors prison line break for Life yeah
the way he's like um spacing all the
yeah that's what really points to me
towards some heavy drug use very bizarre
that he thinks like he's doing something
with like yeah the way
he's artistically spacing things here he
is quote tweeting you know Matt Walsh
and they are from the same organization
but Matt Walsh is undisputably the most
hateful bigoted freak genocidal
freak and uh they're buddies I guess
DeSantis obviously has advisers telling
him to adopt a personality that isn't
natural firm oh that's Matt actually the
awkward fake smiling is part of that he
needs to fire those idiots whoever they
are and just be
himself yes yes a thousand times
yes he said so here let's let's check on
this video
Curious despite my Pro
proclivity my proclivity procity to feel
guilt which is quite substantive and
despite my temperamental unwillingness
to engage in Conflict procity not only
do I not see what I did wrong that's
what he said when has he ever what he's
uh he never backs down on anything he's
guilt Rd
what I think what I've done on the
Public Communication front is my
responsibility as a
clinician to tell the truth about what I
see so we'll make it
public look at this self-important
such an this man really
thinks there's going to be like
textbooks about
him maybe there will be like the the the
the part about like the Takeover of
white nationalism in the wake of uh Maga
leader uh Jordan Peterson
uhhuh hi hello
daughter it's nice of you to say hello
good to see you again let's get lunch
after the podcast and catch up a bit
maybe I'll see you uh next time I'm in
Los
Angeles don't
call I'm not watching this whole thing I
was hoping there'd be like uh
highlights one day ago how many people
watch this probably a lot despite
my procity 1.3 million me
man wow how are they watching people
love him thank you they love him well
timed oh here he is talking to ramas
Swami oh oh how fantastic yeah that's
meeting of two great minds right there
fantastic
um there it is there it is said it all
so we talked about firefest we talked
about lizo although I wish we didn't
for my sake uh Jordan
Peterson uhuh we talked about Logan Paul
um I some mug shot we haven't talked
about we
haven't we haven't that is true you say
uh we just earlier uh ELO sent these
photos of her uh nails and I we never
got we had moved on by the time I got to
him so pull him
up and there's one
stunning sorry I'm everything up
that's the sameoto what is
this I accidentally started some
slideshow or something s my
brain oh my God what is happening stop
stop stop that's an iPhone thing right
it might have been they look great I'm
just trying to get out of here
the audience still hasn't seen it I'm
like struggling right now go to there we
go got it oh I love them there they are
so sorry everything was going crazy for
me uh before we look at the Trump mug
shot this shot what do you think I see
that was a different perspective
different
perspectives what do you think this guy
was arrested
for
uh oh my
God different
perspectives different
perspectives all right let's look at the
Trump mug shot because this was a pretty
big deal yesterday me and Hassan were
eagerly anticipating it and here it is
they got him and they took gentlemen we
got
him shut up here it is we've all been
waiting
for now I was hoping for a smile but he
really gave us the blue steel didn't he
he did the scowl I'm with you I wish he
had smiled I think that would have been
so that would have been a baller move
mhm be like I'm not even worried about
this he looks guilty as in this yes
exactly he looks worried he looks
worried cuz I'm sure that they had like
extensive conversations about what kind
of face he should make M and somehow
this is what they they I feel like
that's his face when he's in the mirror
and he thinks he's looking good that's
his smile I think he's kind of hot how
could they do this to I think he looks
kind of fire if I'm G to be honest yeah
he's kind of cute here's what if he was
smiling he could have looked really good
and here we have an artist rendition he
looks hot
God super super good that looks great
mhm wow definitely should have done that
so we got
Donnie you know um I just saw it this
morning I just realized I don't think
it's in the dock but um Kanye West's uh
former publicist was also arrested as
part of this Rico thing and she she her
mug shot was released today and she
cheesed for the camera hardcore it's
crazy let me pull it up Kanye's
publicist was involved in the
frauding yeah really what did she do uh
she actually what she did is actually
pretty crazy like one of the more overt
like obviously super illegal parts of it
she misrepresent she went to one of the
election officials houses and
misrepresented herself of who she was
and tried to get basically threatened
her trying to get her to um confess on
tape that she had rigged the election
wow so she was like impersonating a
public official and like held somebody
against their will she sounds like a
really good public yeah uh there you go
he just wrote a uh uh is a publicist
here yeah and here is She's accused of
visiting the cob County home of election
worker Ruby Freeman claiming to be a
crisis manager and told Freeman to
confess to committing election frog or
risk being arrested MH wow threaten to
arrest her and this is her uh
Earl that's awesome the smile of the
fake Trump that's what I say that's what
reminded me of it as soon as he pulled
that up I was like wait the girl kind of
smiled like that um here's we got his
stats okay God this is something we've
all been waiting for too but to me the
numbers seem a little funny
okay this is Awesome by the way his rap
sheet uh
racketeering violation of Georgia Rico
dude that's
crazy let's see it says his stats here
he is white I believe believe that
63 mhm and then 215 lb yeah no way now
here here is someone who made a Tik Tok
that I thought was very good check this
out regarding the
215 just okay tell me what you think
about
this for everyone's reference this is a
picture of me taken very recently I am
6'4 and 215 lb
that is all and he's taller than him
dude there's no way he doesn't weigh
like 300 yeah yeah how does he but how
did he get the police to lie about it
apparently all they did is probably ask
him what's your weight and he said the
number and you don't think they weigh
him yeah that makes sense then he
probably neoti he walks around saying
I'm 215 yeah I'm 2 you know what he
probably did negotiate yeah no he's so I
mean the guy is obsessed with image
obviously and and I there was the famous
incident when he was president where uh
he got the presidential doctor or
whatever to obviously lie like his
health is fantastic he has the health of
a 18-year-old man right and it was a
similar thing where his height was his
weight was recorded as like 200 flat or
something and people were like what the
are you talking about yeah he's
over 300 if I I guess 3 at close to 300
he's 325 I think and is he's pretty tall
the devil gets chills when the nice guy
loses his temper though so maybe that's
why they lied for him should
kill me yeah this meme template is so
good not the same without Walt
Jr and then something really happened
because this caused Trump to make his
first Twitter post since being banned in
January
2021 he's so back he's so back here it
is our boys back on X mug shot August
24th election interference Never
Surrender
donaldjtrump.com he's
fundraising this is a horrible thing
this this is just dog I think it's
kind of
fire like this image and the fact that
the text is just so simple and stuff I
don't know there's something powerful
about this image I think so too yeah
yeah doesn't even look centered exactly
it's there's something there's something
about the aesthetic I find really
striking here let's it's in you
everybody's going to look for this
picture I might as well just post it
myself right and get all the god this
yeah they they were instantly selling
shirts with the mug shot on it of course
it's a good move I mean it is like
strategically like I mean it was obvious
turn it turn turn the L into a w he
really waited for the Twitter comeback
for the right time I feel like too dude
his website looks like a goddamn scam
landing page look at this what the
this is a horrible weird a mistake
I think supposed to left I think so
supposed to
Center he's not good at centering
stuff uh okay and
finally oh no he called into the Greg
Kelly show to discuss his his evening in
jail yes I haven't seen this dude
okay in
jail
terrible experience uh I came in I was
treated very nicely but know it's it is
what it is I took a mug shot which I
never heard the words mug shot that
wasn't didn't teach me that at the
Warton School of finance and I have to
go through a process
it's you know that better than can we
analyze that for a second I'm sure a lot
of his friends from Business Schools
probably know about mug shot he just
claimed he didn't know what a mug shot
was right he's being factious right I
mean he's being silly I guess guess he's
like a guy of my status yeah absurd
right who went to the Wharton School
right I think that's yeah he like name
drops his school too it's just
what the was that they're like oh
no bad mention mshot that was didn't
teach me that at the wart School of
finance and I have to go through a
process it's uh election interference
you know that better than anybody you
cover it so well you just and fantastic
job I have to tell you for the listen
fantastic job Greg but it's a very sad
and it's a very sad day for our country
his night in jail didn't wasn't he in
there and
out he didn't go to a cell no not at all
yeah yeah no he's in and out the whole
thing was like 20 minutes from what I
saw 30 minutes or something and here we
looked at this yesterday but it it is
good this is everybody now the whole
gang is here the whole gangs here wait
is trumpy H in here oh yeah there he is
look at this hila these are all the
freaks yep the whole gang that that Kane
PR lady she's wild that picture is so
funny she's so wild that there was one
other person who smiled right oh it was
Jenna Ellis uh second second row on the
left
yeah yeah she was cheesing too is this a
father oo yeah yeah what what what did
he do
I cuz I read through all this a couple
weeks ago I from what I remember he a
prominent uh uh preacher in uh Georgia
and what was it exactly that he do he he
was used to to pressure somebody or
other so all of these are related to
yeah yeah yeah these are all these are
all people that in one way or another
were trying to overturn the election in
they're I think they're considered
co-conspirators who's the one on the
right from Trump is that the crazy guy
this dude or this dude no that this dude
I don't recognize him okay um I saw
something about him that he's actually
the only one that didn't get a uh a bond
uh release which people have pointed out
well I guess now now the Kanye lady's
there too but at the time he was the
only black person that is kind of bad
protic but he actually did do something
fairly heinous from what I recall too um
which was part of it um I can't
keep all their names straight there this
conspiracy is's too big there's too many
parties yeah there's actually um another
mug shot that just dropped really yeah J
shett oh no oh he even looks so hot in
conspirator you can't make this guy look
bad well let's see what he did at his
eyes Ethan yeah we'll see what he did
we'll see we'll see when the facts come
out uh the let's see this is about the
the priest he faces five counts in the
indictment handed by the grand jury in
connection with his alleged attempt to
pressure Georgia
electors Georgia election workers Ruby
Freeman to falsely admit to committing
election fraud the
just what Jesus would do Bo tell
you what man Jesus would would want you
to tell the
truth just say it
you did election
fraud just say it I'm used to grooming
kids this whole grooming of adults thing
is new to me now a little bit harder
crack these
nuts not crack nuts let me tell you
boy I crack nuts like you ain't never
seen one day out when I was on Pastor
there
Zach you're not gonna do it he's not
biting seriously he's not
biting wow okay tough crowd I don't know
what's going on with Zach you got
somewhere to go what's
up uh you actually do have somewhere to
go Ethan I should point out yeah so guys
thank you everybody happy
Friday another great week of shows gamer
Subs guys let's get on the sub Nation
yeah yeah
su su su su
su uh love the new flavor thank you
everybody uh so I guess you know to you
on
Sunday all right I guess I'll be there
vote for J Shetty oh yeah for the Among
Us we need a picture of you and
shete just all mad should ask him that
would be funny you think he's heard
about me with all talk I have no idea
probably not I have no idea probably not
he's in Nana inside meme it's not like
anything actual you know happen between
you guys yeah probably not cuz I'll get
a picture very oneid of beef that would
be perfect J
shett damn you
sh um Al righty have a great weekend
we'll be back on Monday as usual and
look forward to us winning the podcast
uh award on Sunday or else
can I point something out yeah I've been
thinking it but I didn't want to say it
until the end no button today wow I
should have buttoned that lizo
you guys are going to f there were
people would green well anyways we don't
need to relitigate it the song's almost
over we got to wrap this up it's going
to be so embarrassing if this restarts
okay everybody uh have a great weekend
and we will see you on mondek bye bye
[Music]
and